so you
[Music]
can perfect
what's up everybody i am dopaziola
welcome to the first episode of the dope
as usual podcast we are here to talk
about life problems accomplishments
drugs and everything in between
guys this is the very first episode this
is a long-awaited uh
project for
marty and i marty right here jurassic
graphics that's my producer what up
marty
um guys first episode for those of you
that aren't a fan already
let me tell you a little bit about
what's been going on
we've been trying to do this for over a
year we've been trying to get it done
and like i said i know a majority of you
here
that are listening are fans but if
you're not a fan already and you have no
idea who the [__] i am i'm gonna explain
today a little bit give you a little
backstory on why we're here why we're
listening and how this is gonna be fun
as [__] so guys
real quick just like other podcasts i
have to do the ad read you ready today's
uh video today's podcast today's episode
is sponsored by us
nobody gave a [__] we paid for this by
ourselves yeah this is our warehouse man
we got a [__] warehouse because we
wanted to do this right
at the first we were like how could we
design the other room in my apartment
how's it going to look cool and then i
thought i don't want to bring guests to
my apartment to do podcasts like i'm
[__] 19. i just can't do it dude plus
i don't want people in my [__] house
got to be honest um yes guys first
episode my name is thomas my my real
name is thomas i go by dope ozil on the
internet i'm just gonna give you a
little back story
the way i sum it up to everyone at the
elevator pitch what do you do for a
living i smoke weed for a living that's
that's at the essentially at the base
the core of everything i do is weed i
[__] with weed i make weed videos fun
stuff reviews
stories about i used to sell weed my
whole life so that's what i do my name
is dopaziola and i get high as [__] for
a living for those of you that don't
know who i am so in 2012 i started
instagram just started posting pictures
posted weed pictures
thought it was fun started gaining a
following started doing
recreating scenes with weed like i did
the reservoir dogs he chops marvin
nash's ear always slices it off i did
that with nugs i had the little nug
slicing a part of the head off of the
nug like just stupid [__] i did ramble
first blood a bunch of dead bodies
just
fun man i always put myself as remember
in forrest gump when he's really not
there at the college and he hands the
lady or book that's what i did i did
stuff that you had to think
is this a real picture
but no guys i just want to [__] with
people that's all that's all i ever want
to do i want to make funny [__] i want
to make you laugh like i say i'm bobby
i'm bobby hill i'm all pop culture
everything in my life is just revolves
around references i'm the cable guy but
i'm not weird i grew up on tv my mom's
like hey
sit down and watch this while i go do
drugs like so that's how i grew up so
that's tv raised me that's why i did so
many pictures with weed
like i said i started posting more got a
big following started getting paid to go
two places and do reviews for videos and
stuff like that try this weed and then
it got to the point where hey here's
some money here's the weed can you do a
video and that's when i realized i am
getting paid to smoke [__] weed
coolest job on the planet i am
probably the luckiest person that you
could think of and it's so weird when i
go to sleep and i don't think of that
when i wake up i don't think of that
then somebody reminds me like yo
you have the coolest job in the [__]
world yeah i do it's really [__] fun
so that's what i do guys i um have a
youtube channel we just had a million
subscribers yeah
[__] yeah guys we hit a million even
though youtube deleted us
5 000 away from a million i get
constantly i got deleted off instagram
today
i text marty hey i made a new account
two hours later text money it's gone
i know that was true right it was like
two hours later marty not even you're
like yeah we'll see how long this one
stays up for just for fun it's at like
20k you got 20k in a couple hours by the
time our youtube video was uploaded that
[__] was gone yeah guys um so that uh
that that's what happens i get to leave
off the internet i think we're just too
explicit
i used to
sell drugs
care package we got our first care
package coming in guys
i hope it's weed
with this care package just keep going
for you call of duty fans
and
it's gone all right so guys um
yeah this is the first episode so
bear with me i've never talked
just for a [__] hour and a half i've
never done that without having to do
cuts because when i make videos i edit
that [__] i am not doing everything in
one take it's impossible i'm smoking
mass amounts of weed i [__] my words up
so
this is the first one guys this is fun
for me i'm super
[__] excited i am so
excited guys this is it everyone that's
been following me we've been talking
about the podcast for a year it took
nine months to find to find this
warehouse it took nine months during
covet nobody wanted our money
nobody wanted to greet me [__] i think
they were googling my name and they said
i'll get this [__] guy out of my
warehouse gonna grow wheat here i don't
grow weed
excuse me but i think that's what
happened we put marty's name on it got
it first one first one they're like yeah
come come down you gotta deposit and
then we got the warehouse dude
it didn't work
that's exactly what happened um
so yes that's what we've been doing to
take nine months we got this set built
shout out to steve and gary they came
over here took a couple dabs built our
[__] deanna painted it looks bomb as
[__] marty designed it oh no deanna
designed it i think yeah it was a
drastic graphics drastic graphics
project guys it was awesome it looks
great
thank you guys for being here so
i want to get straight into it i want to
talk about like i said this is the first
episode so if you don't know where we
who we are what we've been doing i just
want to give you a back story that way
you're not
you might be listing this in your car on
the way to work it's raining hard as
[__] in southern california you have no
idea what's going on but if you're in
your car it's the first time you ever um
listen to anything i've done or first
time you ever heard of me what's up guys
what's up nice to meet you my name is
thomas i like to smoke weed i make a lot
of stuff i make videos i own a clothing
company called right here push trees
just made it as a joke and now it's
it's one of the top uh streetwear brands
right now and i'm really happy to say
that guys it's it's so [__] weird to
say
what do you do i make uh i smoke weed
for a living what do you do oh yeah i
make clothes is it do good it does great
i always forget about that because we're
so busy we have the podcast we have
three other businesses we have a couple
pages so i'm trying to
make my life this is the point turning
point guys this is it episode one i'm in
the middle of a transition in my life
where everything is starting to work
right for the past eight years i haven't
been getting paid remember i said
earlier i started getting paid that was
last year i just started getting paid
doing this before
it was just clothing i sold clothing to
pay my rent so i can make more videos do
this now we got the warehouse
everything's just
everything's coming together so thank
you guys for being here if you're on
your way to work if you're on your way
to your homies if you're just chilling
with your homies what's up guys this is
on [__] an actual platform like
spotify apple wherever you're listening
to this
holy [__] i know man i know i'm i'm
excited i'm as excited as you are
for everyone that's a fan what's up
thank you for [__] supporting me
thank you for supporting everything we
do we are officially on the platforms
guys we get deleted on instagram all the
time so always they always think of me
as like a [__] drug dealer because
i was a drug dealer but now we're we're
trying marty we're trying we're getting
there we're getting uh to where they
might give us that blue check mark we'll
see um
yeah guys uh this is it i just wanted to
start off right there and since you know
what i've been doing for the past eight
nine years like i said making the videos
starting the brands making content you
might have seen me in a bunch of [__]
weed memes i'm sure you have them that's
all over the internet guys
this is
what i've been trying to do my whole
life i've since i was a child since i
was a little little [__] kid i've
wanted to do something with tv i want to
do something with movies acting and then
i just straight gave up because i was
working going to college and then this
fell in my lap this fell in my lap it
allows me to do whatever i want i get to
make people laugh and when people come
up to me in public and they're hyped
they're hyped like i was when i was a
kid if i would have met [__] adam
said like you know what i mean adam
sandler brett favre were my heroes as
kids
so if i would have met them as kids
that's how i'm that's that i feel like
that's the same reaction i've had
[__] grown ass men just literally cry
so [__] i mean i love it it's so fun
knowing that people are just happy
that there's a new video they're happy
to get a response like i love that man
if i can make someone's day by doing
just what i should do you know i'm
saying just what i should be doing it
was giving back taking the time out to
talk to people
that is the ultimate that's why i didn't
charge for so long i just love doing it
and if i can make someone happy by just
doing what i love
man rich if i ever get rich that's
awesome but if i don't this is super
[__] cool this is enough for me
knowing that there's a bunch of people
out there that are super [__] happy
when they think of the stuff i've done
that's enough for me so
now that we're on there guys i want to
take you back i want to take you back a
little bit i'm gonna light up one of
these [__] joints
um so
yeah i i can smoke weed on spotify right
we can get high on here yeah i'm gonna
light this [__] up
okay guys let's light this up and i'm
going to get into
the beginning i want to get into the
very start you know where i'm doing what
i'm doing now
you know um well the basis of it what
i've been doing the past couple years
let me tell you about my little bit
about my life and this will give you a
better
i guess grasp on the type of person or i
am
i just want to give you the backstory
this is my this is my origins episode
this is episode one all right so bear
with me here we go let me light this up
sorry one sec
there it goes
if any of you guys are falling asleep
because it's so calm it's raining
that's that's that's slow soft-ass
soothing sound we did that on purpose
yeah we did it on purpose we actually
asked the government to make it rain
today
and they did well i meant make it rain
like give me money and then this is what
happened but i'll take it
here we go
guys
real quick let's do this i am from
merced california oh care package coming
in hot
whoa
all right care package we get a lot of
those out here it's la guys someone's
getting shot every five [__] seconds
there's helicopters all day yesterday
was a police chase i left my warehouse
and somebody got shot with a shotgun
that was crazy
here we go
guys i'm from merced california if you
have no idea what merced is or where
it's at
it's is exactly in the middle of the
state of california it is
straight dog [__] it is a
trash [__] town i love that
i'm from there so i can say that i
always say that you can't talk [__]
about merced unless you're from merced
merced sucks
it doesn't have much to do there's meth
cps paperwork section 8
people asking for money outside of
jack-in-the-box
tweakers that's pretty much yes thank
you for bringing it up on the screen
yeah looks like we're oh you guys saw in
the news six inmates escaped from jail
that's merced all those mexican kids
that just ran out of jail that's how
poorly operated our town is that you're
like yo i don't want to finish my
sentence well there's the door that's
exactly merced guys
yeah there it is right there wait three
more escaped
oh no three who escaped or caught yeah
you know it's get the [__] out of here i
i'm rooting one time that i'm rooting
for these criminals man like yo get out
of there because that sucks so i'm from
merced guys i grew up there my whole
life i lived in la for a year lived in
fresno for a year when i was a kid
um
my mom
my mom had me at 18 had my sister at 16
so my mom was a kid raising kids
so a little back story when i was a
child my mom was cool now when i was a
child my mom was a [__] [__]
my dad been cool forever super on drugs
but always worked he always smoked crank
i didn't know that until i was older but
he always worked i just thought he was
you know he had wide eyes
i just thought he doesn't like food
during the day but no it's because he
was on crank and he would be on one for
three days straight
i remember there was a you guys know
costco pizzas here's a reference you
guys know the size of a [__] costco
pizza the big ones right
they're massive they're the size of my
back they're huge so
i remember it was my dad's weekend after
my mom and dad broke up went to my
grandma's that's where like the meeting
place was and my dad he was gone we had
him for the he had us for the weekend
he was gone both days he comes back the
last day from working
falls asleep
doesn't say anything i'm shaking him and
i kind of got worried because he would
not wake up and i could see him
breathing so i just left him alone this
man slept for like 12 hours
i went outside it was the next morning
on monday i went outside to [__] to
[__] around
came back in and my dad was on the last
like three pieces of that pizza
and that's when i realized like
oh you're on drugs you haven't ate in
three days your body just said hey it's
dying you want to get that pizza and
that's where i caught him at
um later on i would be smoking my little
shitty joints and blunts in the in the
field while my dad was hiding from me so
he could snort his little [__] lines
of crank and i thought i was slick with
scott ducey and nick [__] oh we're in
the bush mom my dad's busy he's in the
garage he his know what we're doing and
little does my dad a little we know my
dad's in there ah they're out there
smoking weed trying to pretend that
they're not smoking weed i'm gonna do my
crap
yo but real quick for being a crank can
my whole life
my dad's whole life when i was younger
he's funny as [__] he's a nice ass
[__]
and he's sober now so that's cool but he
always worked so i always give it to my
dad my mom too she had two jobs my whole
life even though she was smoking meth
when i was younger
but um
that's my life i grew up i am a brown as
you can see i'm brown i do not speak
spanish and i'm in a mexican town
you can probably guess how that went for
me growing up i was shunned i was
shunned at every family party like no
espanol
that's my thing
and then look at my dad and my grandma
ah
like
[__] you guys you know like
[__] you that's how i always thought
like [__] man i don't speak spanish why
don't you guys teach me you [__] i'm
just going to say
teach me you pieces of [__] i'm over
here trying to i remember how many times
i had to translate from my grandpa
to people coming over the house like you
uh ups guy or [__] satellite dish guy
i remember one time i'm trying to like
grandpa
he needs it
smaller
and i'm looking at the guy that speaks
english he's looking at me
like ah this is stupid
i'm not gonna have a kid translate that
doesn't speak the [__] language that
i'm trying to translate he could have
done that that's the one time i remember
thinking yeah i need to learn spanish
man this is bad and when i went to
mexico i got made fun of a lot
you just thought you'd have picked up on
the basics though i know the cane
this is it i know when you're talking
[__] about me
i know if you're gonna jump me i know if
you're gonna
that's just more vibes that's more vibes
that's violent
no no because
because
i know
i know the basics of like hey let's jump
this [__] guy like i know that that's
why i need to learn spanish because i
went to spa uh damn i went to spanish
with my
i went to mexico with my grandma when i
was like 20 and we were waiting at a
stoplight guys
and what i heard made me never want to
go back to mexico this guy behind me is
talking to this regular looking mexican
man in a plaid shirt and
boots regular man
this is in tijuana in the middle of the
of in the middle of the earth in the
town that these people live in this
guy's regular looking dude is talking to
some gangster ass fool i mean
face tatted 13 on his [__] cheeks but
he's speaking uh english proper ass in
english too so it's like oh you're from
america you're just chilling in mexico
right that's what i think
i what i hear next makes me just like
cringe i didn't want to turn around i
just walked with my grandma like let's
get get me the [__] out of here grandma
i don't want to be
i am a real american that's how i felt
like [__] hulk hogan like yo mexico's
not for me bro
what you just said made me just [__]
want to hulk out what can wear american
flags and never come back because it
scared the [__] out of me
this man straight up start talking to
this guy behind me i'm waiting to stop
light goes do you hear about he said a
spanish name i don't know how to say it
he said this names i hear about
so-and-so and he goes yeah fool what the
[__] why'd you do that she goes that
wasn't me he said i don't do [__] like
that that's what god put they said they
burned that fool i don't do stupid [__]
like that this man says
i didn't do that one
they burned him i don't do [__] like
that
this man basically said oh i'm a killer
you know i'm a killer you thought i
burned that guy oh i wouldn't burn
somebody
that was a casual conversation these
guys were having and i will it will
never
never not be in my brain because i
remember thinking
oh you just oh this is a sport for you
you don't give a [__] you're openly
talking about this [__] i'm out and then
i stayed awake all night in the hotel
watched a boxing match that was super
staticky like uh
home alone too when they get [__]
stuck in miami and their tv is all
shitty that's how it was
uh woke up the next day went to the
place that my grandpa took me to the
doctor he wanted to put a needle in my
back and i went uh [__] you and my
grandpa got pissed i didn't want to do
it
and i came back and i never i never left
and i've been in america since
no i went to mexico in cancun but that
was to a resort
i'm fine with that
but that's where they made fun of me for
not speaking spanish
marty how the [__] did we get off on
this topic oh
my oh yeah i don't speak spanish
so yeah i'm from merced it's full of uh
trash martin you want to pull up some
merced merced statistics and or pictures
i seem to remember that there was
somebody that did end up teaching you
spanish though right um
the
like five words
so i know this sounds really [__]
stupid guys and this is episode one
we'll have more time to get to know each
other all right my mom
my mom's mom is jewish my grandma's
jewish uh
pol she's like family's from poland they
they're they're
whatever the [__] you want to say
they're jewish we try to do hanukkah and
all that [__] right but my mom's dad is
my grandpa tom he's from
texas and he's spaniard so he's like he
looks just like john like uh
oh [__] what's his name chanch
come on marty come on what's his name
from [__] chips
punch punch erika's try to punch sonic
that's your cousin
um
yeah my grandpa looks just like erica
straw my grandpa was a good looking ass
[__] man and um
my grandma was jewish and that's they
had my mom right
so my mom is a whiter looking mexican
lady but she's very light-skinned
all my life my mom says you join a gang
i [__] kill you you hit your
girlfriend i will [__] stab you if
you sag your pants i'll break your
[__] leg my mom's a dick but she got
me on the right path if not i would have
been a [__] little gang banging piece
of [__]
totally i'm i love her for doing that to
me anyway
my mom's anti-gang
and decided to marry a [__] white
supremacist
standard
what the [__] i know it sounds so stupid
right yeah right your mom married a
white supremacist mexican jewish lady
bro
those five to six years of my life were
a roller coaster of learning
all right i just had to learn all of the
these cultural differences and getting
stared at at the gas station because my
stepdad's completely [__] tatted and
oh i can't get into all the tattoos but
he did have white is right going all the
way down his [__] leg and i remember
i asked him he goes it's just from
prison and that's when he explained to
me racism in prison racism out of prison
because my best friend was black
my [__] best friend was black and his
dad was a share of the
top like buffest cop in our town and he
knew my stepdad from them
being he was a criminal my stepdad was a
oh i didn't say it i said that as a
criminal my mom first time i ever met
him
he had hair down to his to his uh like
back of his knees he was showing me
hacky sack with no shirt
and overalls
so i don't think he had much to do that
day he sounds like an episode of ozark
you know he didn't have much
oh sorry
you know my stepdad was mad
mad smart like
unbelievably smart he has a lot of
degrees and a lot of felonies so when he
tried to be a teacher they told him bro
it's not gonna happen you've done a lot
of
uh 31 rapes and merced
sorry just pull that up like oh my god
sorry if you guys didn't i just talked
about my stepdad and just go rape sorry
marty pulled up his ground overlay these
graphics people i hope you do
he pulled up this graphic and merced
just sucks man
um
but yeah uh anyway
my stepdad knew flew in spanish because
i can't get into fully everything but he
did crazy [__] in prison he told me a
lot of wild [__]
when my mom and him started getting
divorced and i started getting older i
was like 12 or 13 he like started
telling me more
and the [__] he told me made me like
i live with you
you're capable of this crazy [__] full i
slipped my door unlocked
what the [__]
anyway um he spoke fluent spanish and he
tried to teach me some words because i
didn't know any spanish so i want you to
wonder years yourself out of this
situation
let me back up and look over
exactly
so imagine little fat [__] brown kid
and buff as [__] step dad i almost said
his damn name oof it's a tv show yeah
buff as [__] step dad
rock the [__] out with lightning bolts
white is right and [__]
what was it uh what are those vikings
that's what got us kicked out of
disneyland uh we didn't even make it in
we were in the line they told us we had
to leave um because he shaved his head
one day and he has his whole head tatted
it's all racist [__] anyway
um he's sitting there trying to teach me
spanish words
and i remember thinking my dad is not
trying to teach me spanish and this
white supremacist [__] that's
basically my dad i started calling my
dad toward the end because he my dad was
not around he was on drugs even though
he was a cool [__] he didn't
show up to any of my [__] i was a
captain of the [__] football team
look at one gold mess uh medals of
wrestling he didn't show up for [__]
unless it was for sports he would like
say i had 15 games he showed up for one
and i'm around
it's a long story now that i'm thinking
about like god that's sad
jesus christ but um so my stepdad was
always there that was like my dad he was
teaching me like rules of this uh if you
see anybody flash this kind of hand sign
you do not talk to him you go away you
do this you don't he was showing me all
the gang life to stay the [__] out of it
he always used to tell me you're too
[__] nice to go to jail never go to
jail he always said if i ever find out
you're doing drugs i'm gonna beat the
[__] out of you not like a dad beats a
kid i'm gonna beat your [__] ass and
i remember i was about 12 when he said
that and i thought
well i guess i'm not doing drugs because
you're gonna beat the [__] out of me
because i'm never gonna beat your ass
you're a monster and um
then he got hooked on meth and my mom
just stopped being married to him
that was it guys
everybody preaching all this [__] not
leading by example what the [__] man
good thing i had the same brain as a
child
as a kid i've been thinking the same way
people irritate me get the [__] away
from me i don't like you and i i was
always right they always ended up being
a creep but he taught me spanish
my mom taught me how to throw a football
my dad taught me uh
cool
movies from the 90s i think that was it
it's valuable it is i mean rambo first
blood terminator one those are deep
those are deeply
ingrained movies in my brain man
um
yeah so that's merced i grew up around
that
and uh i don't speak spanish so
everybody used to [__] with me because
i'm in a
primarily mexican town
everybody used to talk [__] to me at the
flea markets i was always getting
shunned
and i didn't give a [__] i was sitting
there just playing football and
trying to get good grades and that was
me as a little kid and then later on i
just started selling weed about 15 i
started selling [__] mass amounts of
weed with my homies planting
sacks on the night the sunday if it was
monday we'd go on sunday plant all of
our sac 10 sex dubs are on this side
it's under this bush it's by this it's
in this drain pipe it's by this piece of
wood at the wood shop so at lunch
we go what do you need 20 be right back
i'd walk to the certain spot where i had
20s make sure no one's there grab one
come out me and joe my friend my best
friend he was my best friend joe fish
the first time we started selling weed
uh
one lunch period we sold an entire ounce
and it doesn't sound like a lot
but 28 sales basically like a gram your
energy was 20 bucks back then
we made almost 500 maybe a little over
and we didn't have money
it's like a sale every other month no
dude we were selling a sack and every
three minutes that person would bring
somebody back like yo this is the guy
right here but what do you want let me
get your money all right cool you know
how many ones and fives i've taken for
ten sacks it's unbelievable dude it is
crazy um the ten sacks were point fours
like yo what about point five you have a
gram for twenty like uh sorry if you
want twenty you gotta buy the whole gram
if you want
if you want a dead sack it's gonna be
the point four
[Laughter]
oh yeah oh yeah
it's merced
it's merced uh if anybody found out who
no you can't tell on somebody selling
weed because then the weed connects gone
you're gonna be shunned
no
no no one's paying attention
no one's paying well it's me and joe i
did what 12 15. joe sold all the girls
he's super pretty so you just sell all
the girls bam just like that my homie
was mad pretty then he [__] it all up
but uh yeah he would sell to all the
chicks he would always [__] skimp
them i would sell to all the [__]
dudes i knew there was a time in 10th
grade where i would walk up to you know
the groups the jock kids oh the water
polo kids oh these kids
we're mexican towns so the water polo
kids are the only white kids you know
what i'm saying the only white kids the
one mexican kid that just that just
happened to join the team he's friends
with them that's pretty much how my town
is unless you go across town golden
valley and that's where all the white
kids go to school because merced high
where i went is the ghetto at school
so
unless you want your daughter pregnant
don't go to merced high basically
uh
yeah i just started selling we like that
guys i know it's a long origin story but
at least it's not like [__] wolverine
it's all sad my little brother cried
when wolverine died
it's more like 300. he went off into the
tundra and sold his own packs at lunch
yo dude
yesterday i was thinking of stuff of
three i was thinking of a quote from 300
and i started doing that voice in my
head marty
i'm not kidding
i wish i could have someone narrate my
life like that
oh and he got the other cheese oh he put
that one that one looks processed yo
just me at the grocery store certainly
not vegan yeah not vegan cheese don't
touch it oh yeah i know i'm super fat i
don't eat meat or cheese i'm vegan for a
long time
um i used to be fatter because everybody
asked you're still fat like bro trust me
i was a lot worse than this before i
stopped so yeah that'll be a thing a
common
talking terms man we make some my
girlfriend rosie makes some
super sick [__] i love pinterest you can
make meatloaf out of beans and lentils i
don't know if you knew that and carrots
and onions yeah it's [__] bomb
um
so yeah that's merced i started selling
hello weed i moved out started selling
a lot more weed after high school i
started selling
packs and i started taking trips to get
packs and going to santa cruz and
getting 20 pack coming back and it's all
gone uh my homie well
i'll let's just say his name's john
let's keep it john
from uh i do these things called story
times if you don't know and i just
tell a few stories sit down for 30
minutes smoke weed it's my number one
asked for thing on youtube
and uh i love it it's my favorite thing
to do just talk it's just talking having
fun telling stories about i've been
through some crazy [__] man i've almost
been killed i've almost been [__] sh
i've almost been killed
i've almost accidentally killed people
i've almost gone to prison i've almo
there's so much i still haven't talked
about on my youtube because like i said
i do story time i'm in season three i'm
in season three of this [__] and um
let's just call him john john used to be
one of my dealers he was my
the
all right now now that i know he was the
best connect with the worst habits
the coolest kinect the dopest one with
the worst
[__]
mindset ever nicest guy super cool one
of the funniest people i know only
person i know that could freestyle for
three or four minutes non-stop just high
and not make me cringe
and i'm not like oh bro that was
terrible yo you're really good at this
you should do this more often one of my
i love the guy anyway long story short
he disappeared um
i never really got into it but
i
uh
about
almost two years ago i pretty much came
to terms he's dead because this has been
a almost nine years he's been missing
and
there's just i just don't see a chance
of him being alive still because they
did i never talked about a lot but they
found his [__] dog shot in the head
uh
on the road leading outside by the
hospital
long story short he owed somebody money
he got robbed i told him it's gonna be
good because i owed him like 20 [__]
racks because he gave me so many packs
and then he never answered his phone
again
i remember last time i talked to me said
i just got [__] robbed like what are
you talking about i could tell he's off
the [__] oxygens i can tell in his
voice if you know people that do pills
you you can hear it in their voice
it gets a little more drastic like i
hate that [__] voice and uh
i just gotta [__] rob i'm like what
do you mean you just got [__] robbed
who are you with where are you i'm at a
party go you're at a party with a 40
pack
i am going to punch you in the face the
40 pack is means 40 pounds a week a pack
is one pound
brought a 40 pack to meet a guy at a
party on oxies didn't get punched
nothing full passed the [__] out in one
of the rooms somebody walked in took the
bag and left
he has no he had no idea who it was
i could hear the panic in his voice i'm
like yo it's going to be cool i got 20
bands for you right now you were
supposed to meet me tonight but you're
at a party obviously and uh last time i
ever talked to him that was it he told
me i'm with joe joe my friend joe my
best friend
that was it guys
disappeared i know that guy almost every
[__] day
disappeared
wanted uh missing poster signs from his
mom his brother his other brothers were
my other best friends
well you'll hear a lot more about him
you'll hear a lot about ryan
um this was ryan's older brother uh
let's call him john
yeah he's still missing guys he went
missing when i was like 22.
really sad but uh
yeah i started i got to connect with him
i started pushing so much [__] weed
out of my house it got weird it got to
the point where i started getting scared
like i could potentially get my door
kicked in i'm selling a lot of [__]
weed there's so much foot traffic
but
the best part about it is i lose my
first apartment i lived above
the maintenance worker and i noticed
about day two that the maintenance
worker sells [__] uh chris sells uh
meth
because he kept tweakers kept coming by
and i was thinking
[__] dude there's so much foot traffic
coming in here they're gonna know i'm
selling something
and then when i started realizing like
yo these tweakers are coming in and out
you're selling meth you're the [__]
um janitor basically the gate the
groundskeeper of the apartment that was
the guy he lived under me
and yeah dude sure enough i realized
he's selling meth i said no no no come
come to the door bro i'll serve you at
the door it doesn't matter because this
motherfucker's still a meth below me
ain't nobody's saying [__] if he's not
in jail i ain't going to [__] jail
he's not calling the cops on me
um
best cover i ever had best cover ever so
that's merced that's what happened guys
start selling weed mass amounts of weed
and that leads me up to like i said
um i got a
iphone i mean i got a smartphone posted
on instagram started posting weed
my account started taking off and i had
to stop selling wheat mercedes a small
town so i stopped selling weed because
you either sell weed and you shut the
[__] up you don't let nobody know
or you're on the internet
smoking weed doing crazy [__] and you go
to jail because you still sell wheat so
i decided to take
a different route and just stop selling
weed i got another job to try to help
out with [__] bills just before i
started the clothing company so
i
had no money
i stopped selling weed that was very
[__] luke let's just say it was very
lucrative a little i've made
i made a million dollars before i was
[__] 20 years old and i i literally
have nothing to show for it
don't give kids money don't let kids
with money is just
somebody else is gonna get rich that
kid's not staying rich i'll just say
that
no there's no doubt in my mind that i've
made i made that before i
for a hundred percent i'm selling that
much weight every [__] day this is
back when eight for fifty five dollars
quarters or 110
don't even ask me about the ounce
because you don't want to pay it that's
those days 2007 2008 when i was
taxing 30 dollars a half [__] eighth
i feel bad now but that's that's what i
was charging man my we was fired from
john john was getting straight from
humble blue dot
uh he was getting blue dot blue dream oh
gee he always call it the kush the kush
he never called it og or true you just
called it the kush and that was always
more expensive the perp the dark purp
the hardball perp gdps the regular perp
china perps
um i was getting everything from him
blue dot was a big one
um this is before cookies even came out
before girl scout cookies came out for
all those gelatos this is pre all of
that [__] so there was not much to
choose from but they were all fire man
why i remember chem chem dog too
anyway that brings me up to that stop
stop selling weed started making
weed content and here we are that's my
long ass story
that's where we're at and that's where i
grew up and let me um
introdu i know we introduced marty but i
want this is a team this is a team show
it's not just me all right marty's over
here doing all the cam work doing
everything marty is not from california
marty's from cold ass buffalo and just
to tell you a little bit about marty
he's really nice she's really
professional marty used to also walk
around with a screwdriver
marty uh take it away
[Laughter]
not the intro i was expecting
that's the best intro ever oh he's so
professional and nice also used to carry
a screwdriver for protection so
continue
yeah man it was a long road out to here
at a beautiful socal and we're on top
now but it wasn't always so nice
so you're from buffalo new york yeah man
the only thing i know about buffalo is
is big daddy where are you from buffalo
that's all i know about buffalo what
about uh bruce almighty right that's in
buffalo
bro i did not know that i said it was it
wasn't actually
no idea no that was in studio city
yeah man you know so what's up where you
from you're from buffalo you grew up
there your whole life what's what's
going on let everybody know what's going
on yeah man grew up through the four
consecutive saw you know loop super bowl
losses and going through this past week
has been awfully traumatic oh yeah so
it's just for timing let me cut marty
real quick i'm a packer fan so i was a
kid marty's a die-hard bills fan and
bullfar teams just got kicked out of the
[__] super bowl we were real
optimistic for this we were talking yeah
we did a test from last week and we're
like yeah i wonder who's going to make
it it's sunday night we're both like so
i guess the stress is off because we
don't have to worry anymore it was
stressful it was stressful man i was
sitting there like i just want the bills
to not lose and they [__] got smashed
and packers got [__] murdered
yeah i'm just glad we got our ass beat
and it wasn't close it wasn't like a
fluke we didn't get screwed over they
just beat our ass fan square so yeah
okay with 100 exactly i'm okay with it
tom brady you [__] you're so
damn good at this
but like you're saying though it did
remind me how much like i i felt that
hometown pride for the first time in a
long time seeing us do that a lot of
great things been coming on buffalo this
year so i'm really happy
that's all i know about buffalo zelda
and the bills yeah marty yeah there we
are you know that's it that's fine um so
no no no don't don't go around it why'd
you just carry a screwdriver yeah well i
mean [__] it was uh
oh wait a screw
yeah no what you're talking about is
from yeah particularly this big-ass
screw i used to carry around in my
pocket
yeah i mean there's all kinds of [__]
hold on i know and you used to there was
a handle on it
yeah don't leave it out don't believe it
yeah no it was just it was a step but it
was a poor man's brass knuckles that's
what we're talking about there's a big
ass screw from home depot or some [__] i
could see you too
and that tall ass white tall t
straight build hat ready to punch
somebody in the [__] face
you nailed it yeah
yeah
oh man i love it dude no keep going in
marty what brought you out here uh for
everybody at home what brought you to
california because you've told me the
story the story is quite [__] epic i
it's there's no way around it it's just
[__] epic man it was really just a
mission to get out of buffalo and get
out here
at the time it was all based around
music my you know
we talked about my real passions in life
for basketball and the music i ended up
waging this campaign and making up the
move out here through music and you know
my business graphic design and drastic
graphics hold up don't be skimming don't
be scared i gotta say this for marty
marty's never gonna say the cool [__]
try to he's gonna think he's gonna sound
like a jerk you don't sound like a jerk
mario almost got a [__]
damn record deal that's why marty moved
out here
it was a a strong marathon with the
music for a long time i ended up getting
a deal with dj ski
and then you know i moved out here over
that
and then after you know it was probably
about a year that i really kept going
with music hard before i saw my
opportunities with within podcast and
comedy and then just really just slammed
down drastic graphics full time
and and completely fell back from music
and so i mean it's really come full
circle now though because music's a huge
part of my life with all the video i
work on yeah oh marty forever all the
fans out there all the youtube videos
are edited by marty
all that crazy dope [__] wild ass
edits that's all this guy right here and
that computer right there yep yeah it's
taking a while it's kind of cool to
think about that way um
so you came out here started doing the
graphics and
you started doing podcasting so
basically marty started working with
brian callan and brandon schaub yup
right and that's how you got your start
and then you started working with other
people go ahead and
take it away yeah at the beginning of
the fighter and the kid when you know
rogan was really at his peak and putting
on all his friends with their different
podcasts
i was able to get in on the ground floor
of that and then kind of grow my
business through the comedians and the
podcast community really through rogan
and theo and
josh wolf sickler dove davidoff
a bunch of the a bunch of the comics
and you know really just put me in this
position and podcasting now six seven
years into it
where
you know me and my associates and people
i work with it's kind of like how we say
like in the music industry in the 90s
like the a rs and the execs all the
people that kind of ran the industry
actually i feel like that's what's going
on in podcasting right now
yes yes yes you're getting
the talent walk in walk out we got the
rest that's really what it is who can
make it work and that's pretty much what
you do for a long time for you know
thousands of episodes is the idea
because it's easy to be hot quick it's
easy to come out hot it's easy to have a
hundred good episodes but
episode six seven hundred a thousand
damn
but you the other podcast you work on
don't get care packages dropped in
three to four times an episode they're
sure they sure don't
care package sponsored by
us
once again the [__] there's a war going
on man i don't know what the [__]
going on but that's like third [__]
helicopter and there's never helicopters
so
so barty that's why uh
marty hit me up about a year ago that's
how we connected because i talked about
one do a podcast i posted on my
instagram
i did not know of marty
then uh hit me up says hey i can help
you with the podcast start talking turns
out marty filmed a piece of one of my
videos like six years ago i was at this
weed
like content party thing and we were
filming this video and marty had so
happened randomly randomly be there for
something completely different and then
he started following me since that night
he said just start a phone see what
you're doing i like what you're doing
then he said i saw you talking my
podcast right up my alley and that made
me stoke like okay
you could have hit me up at any time in
these six years but you waited to you're
like no no i can actually do that and i
think it's a good idea that's when it's
like because i hate when people like oh
i can help you do this this this this
this like no
there's not enough time in the day for
you to help me do this this this and
this [__]
i've only gotten that feeling a couple
times in life it was when i remember
distinctively like when i knew like oh
you should hit up fighting the kid this
is about to be this about to be big you
should hit them up yeah it was one of
those moments every once in a while they
happen and it's like moment inspiration
like nah you know what you got to do you
can look into the future and see what it
could be in a second
and then just
a bunch of a bunch of opportunities have
come to fruition like that for me
yeah dude when it works it works
um
so that's how we got together guys and
we just been working on stuff since then
and it's a testament to the fans how
long it took to get this up and running
a year
over a year guys we talked about this
we posted coming soon 11 months ago and
then covet started
but you didn't mark that we could have
very easily we could have asked it just
did it not had a set had a [__] sheet
behind me and just talked and go hey i
got a lot of followers you guys better
watch now [__] that [__] i would love it
if the first episode it was all fans are
all people that don't even know who we
are
that would be bomb if i can capture
those
brains and those that attention of the
people that don't even know who we are
just to talk and hang out and have fun
and
it's gonna get wild on here i haven't
even started really talking about any of
the crazy [__]
and that's what i love i love watching
interviews i love that [__] we're gonna
have our first guest
in a couple days i'm very [__]
excited about we'll tell you who i'm
really excited super funny comedian
and i'm ready to get [__] up with this
guy
that's really i'm ready to get [__] up
we might only my drink we might eat some
mushroom we never know we
it's fun like i said here we talk about
life accomplishment drugs and everything
in between so drugs is a big part of
that [__] um
drugs was my best friend i don't care
what kind of drugs as long as it was fun
but uh drugs will kill you so don't do
that smoke weed
i'ma like this [__] joint you
think conor mcgregor is on drugs
cocaine
i think all fighters do [__] rails
and then walk in and start fighting
could you not how could you not because
i know me when i did cocaine i'm not a
violent person i'm not aggressive i
could probably find a lot longer when i
was doing massive amounts of coke just
to get through the field just
i don't know did you ever wrestle or
anything like that marty
like for school i i mean i've done like
a lot of kickboxing like conditioning
but not like wrestling for school okay
have you ever uh done an individual
sport against somebody like for school
or city just basketball just okay that's
difficult teammates um
because when you said the fear the fear
is not really there totally it's the
blankness like when i used to wrestle
i took that [__] serious and no matter
how many moves and this and all this
[__] i was ready to [__] with
the second they go okay go i go [__]
dude what was i gonna do again and i'm
just kind of like get off of me get the
[__] off of me
everything's gone dude
when it comes to adrenaline everything
is wiped clean you go yo don't let this
fool put you on your back ah [__] i lost
that's pretty much how my wrestling went
for the first two years because i was
fat and short so i was always in
heavyweights even when i was like in
sixth grade i i was gonna get in jiu
jitsu i really wanted to when i was
heavy doing the kickboxing but even then
pre-code that it just i just can't be
all on other dudes all sweaty and [__]
it's just not for me see that for me
it's it's more of i don't think about
that when it's serious when it's serious
i don't give a [__] if you're pissing
your pants
yeah if it was an option about yo can we
just like wear full shirts
do i have to have my [__]
uh spaghetti straps and then just
[__] go bump chests with this guy and
my sister wrestled too dude and my
sister was big
uh she she was like five seven five
eight in fifth grade she just grew her
full so i always got my ass whooped as
kids as a kid she'd beat the [__] out of
me but when she wrestled dude she would
[__] people up and when it comes to
wrestling and you're in sixth seventh
grade you don't wanna wrestle the girl
you feel weird you're like oh i don't
wanna hurt the girl because when you're
a kid you don't learn yet that no no no
girls are wrestlers too you better try
cause she's gonna [__] you up but you
know you're in sixth grade no one taught
you that yet you didn't you didn't
unless you wrestled for the city you
didn't wrestle yet sixth grade was the
first time you wrestled for us you know
i mean you don't have that in fifth
grade so when i remember my sister went
up for her first match i was thinking
well she beats the [__] out of me i hope
she [__] this full i mean she [__]
this kid up so violently and i thought
yo that was that's been me that's been
me for 13 years she's been doing that
[__] to me now everybody else used to
feel it that guy was six one i'm [__]
i i was four eight dude in eighth grade
you felt justified yeah i felt like all
right
yep and then ninth grade came and my
first time ever beat my sister's ass
i [__] her [__] up
last time she ever tried to [__] play
me like that
oh she i think she realized like wait
oh you're strong now like yeah [__]
what are we talking about you did you
like do an ankle pick and no um
so you know let's get into this story
real quick let's get into this my sister
is a [__] [__] to me all my whole
life growing up we're cool now but she
was a [__]
[__] because my mom would always beat
her ass she was always grounded because
my sister has a smart ass mouth she
don't give a [__] about authority and
she talks [__] to my mom my mom is joe
pesci don't [__] with my mom she's a
[__] too but i was very nice and
polite because my mom's mean
so as soon as my mom would get done
beating my sister's ass for being a
dumbass and i would tell her you know
stop she's gonna come in here and [__]
you up as soon as my mom leaves a room
my sister beat my ass because she was
mad that i didn't get beat up or i
didn't get spanked
but it's like yo [__] i didn't do
anything you [__] you
all right i'm gonna get my ass whooped
again so i got my ass whooped all the
time all the [__] time and i was the
smallest so
my mom's a full-grown lady my sister is
basically a full-grown [__] lady i'm
short i was short as [__] and then i got
my growth spurt 9th grade randomly and
grew like [__] 9 inches out of
nowhere
[__] no more like 12. yeah i grew like a
[__] foot out of nowhere and
it was ninth grade guys it's when
playstation twos were still here all
right i had a playstation two
a little backstory i did not grow up
with money so playstation 2 was a big
[__] deal to me it was
gold you right now if you can relate to
me you grew up not [__] you were not
rich we weren't we used to be way worse
when i was younger but
you don't get new clothes all the time
like in your school shopping oh dude i
hope my pants are still okay enough for
this year too it was like that we
weren't [__] dying poor but we didn't
have money so when i had that
playstation 2 actually i just found the
picture of me getting it as a little kid
and uh i had it for like four years or
three years i had that playstation 2.
i'm just playing games man that's all
i'm doing i got off of school i'm a
freshman i lived across the street from
the school like [__]
not another or like a scary movie one i
lived right across the street from the
[__] school
i'm just playing games it's all i'm
doing just playing games my sister's a
[__] [__] does she walk and i'm
not even exaggerating
she walks in
just grabs a remote changes and i go yo
i'm playing games i don't [__] care
oh
you [__] i just remember feeling like
why are you so mean to me that's like i
was never like hurt that she made fun of
me and all this [__] and beat my ass it
was more of
what the [__] did i do to you [__]
what did i do to you okay
why i'm so i'm so nice man so i didn't
understand
she turned it off i went and grabbed the
remote i turned it back
and then she tried to get it from me and
i closed my hand and when i closed my
hand she looked at me like i'm gonna
[__] kill you that's like a south
park uh stan and his sister
that's me
i closed my hand and she looked at me
she tried to get it and i just gripped
it and she tried to open my hand and i
that's when i realized like
oh i'm stronger than you now oh it's
over
you can't do and then she tried to
[__] punch me and i blocked it and
then she tried to punch me again and i
don't know what happened dude i just
grabbed her by her leg and her arm and i
picked her up over my head and i dipped
her literally
i hulked her
so [__] hard i mean i was 9th grade i
was already benching 280 you know um
squatting three so i was a little a
little buff little [__]
and uh
i dipped her and then i hear i can hear
the ah
the air escaping her
and then i can see her trying to catch
her breath
and then at this point dude was like
imagine this imagine this like
a movie where this little guy's just
getting his ass whooped and then the
moment where the the
villain basically my sister realizes
like
i can't do it it's like jafar when like
and everything that goes with it and
jafar gets sucked in the lamp that was
my sister
no
i have her on her back and i grab her
[__] wrist both of them and i'm
holding him and she's trying to move and
she realizes she can't move her arms and
i just push one or grab her wrist put
her arm on her chest do it to the other
chest and i grab both her wrists like
this would your mom teach you this move
exactly exactly exactly
exactly when mom told me not to hit
girls or how to stop girls from hitting
you that's exactly what i did except for
the head part um so i have both her
hands together and i grip it with one
hand and i press all my body weight so
both her hands are under my body weight
she's on her back and i'm looking face
to face with her for the first [__]
time i've ever winning a fight with her
and i'm looking at her and i'm like it's
over and i looked at her and said it's
[__] done you can't do that anymore
it's not get off and she started
screaming at the top of her lungs
so loud that it made me scared i don't
know if that makes sense yeah like
like it hurt me yeah it hurt like my
ears so i'm like oh [__] and i didn't
get off her oh hell no she screamed like
that she's gonna kill my sister tried to
stab me
twice before that legitimately try to
stab me oh man i should mention this
this apartment uh our wall neighbor like
the neighbor that's touching our wall is
my uncle john a man pepper
so my uncle john and my sister uh smoke
weed together and drink my uncle john
was like 22 my sister was like 16.
so
um you know they're kind of close and
easy they just get drunk drink and he
would drink after work he found out she
smoked me like i have we listen mcqueen
michael was the man and uh
yeah and
he lived next door so he's broken up a
few fights because he could hear me
screaming for help because she's to beat
my ass i'd be screaming for help he'd
come over like just stop beating his ass
and then you know that was it
excuse me
so my sister's screaming get off get the
[__] off she's screaming at the top of
her lungs and i remember i look at her
and i just
like slap her
right in the face with my other hand
i popped her and like
oh i filled up with [__] so much
power like i just [__]
i hulk a mania just started shaking like
oh my god that was amazing i slapped i
didn't slap her hard i was just doing
that kind of [__]
and i told like
imagining it now like i see why she was
so mad and for about
15 minutes i was sitting on her stomach
and holding her down and telling her if
i let you up you can't do anything to me
because i know she's crazy she's she
will [__] she'll try to kill me
legitimately and uh
i'm telling you like i'm not gonna let
you up get the [__] off screaming like
screaming into my soul and i'm looking
at her and i'm smiling and it's the
first time that she can't do anything
and i'm like
i'm like i said i'm sitting there
shaking like oh my god yes are you
[__] [__] that's all i keep thinking
like i'm gonna like when ralphie beats
the [__] out of the red-headed kid and
christmas story that's how it was i was
just like oh you [__] and then
i told her i'm gonna let you up
i'm gonna [__] go outside don't do
anything don't it's over if i let you up
it's [__] over don't
and she doesn't say anything she's just
staring at me she's just [__] staring
at me doesn't say anything i'm like i'ma
let you up
and i like release my hand i start
getting up she doesn't move i stand up
and she just looks at me while she gets
up
staring right at me i'm like oh no
what did i do
she looks at me turns around and just
stomps my playstation 2
stops it into into [__] pieces
um that's shitty yeah so she's sitting
there she gets about two stomps in
oh care package i hope it's a ps2
um
she stomps my playstation she gets two
stomps in before i realize like no
and she's only four feet away we're in a
little house apartment she's four feet
away around the coffee table
i start going around the coffee to stop
her and she gets that third stomp in and
when she does that thing just splits it
just cracked in
and i looked at it like
oh my god
what the [__]
and then she immediately
you know i think i just mixed that up
i'm sorry wow i [__] my own store yet
um she stopped my playstation in before
i slammed her that's why i slammed her
sorry i mixed that up this is where it
gets violent that's right i wouldn't
give her the [__] she wouldn't give me
the [__] remote she swung on me i
pushed her and she stomped my [__] in so
i slammed her on the [__] ground
there sorry [__] my story anyway she she
stopped my playstation two pieces and
then i s that's when i put my [__]
hand on her chest and she was get off me
all that [__] anyway i let her up
she'd look she's looking at me she gets
up
and she just
calmly like
calm she runs but calmly no like
she runs like what what are you doing
what are you doing she calmly just goes
to the kitchen comes around with the
[__] the uh
you know the bigger kitchen ones from
the block like not the not the skinny
bread knives the thick ones the michael
myers the butcher there you go butcher
knife thank you
this [__] comes around the corner with
it and i'm like stop stop knock it off
i'm gonna call i'm gonna tell mom i'm
gonna call mom because my mom's away i'm
gonna call mom i was just saying
whatever i could because i know she's
[__] crazy
she got like three steps for me and
swiped and when she swiped there was no
no holding back she swiped going for it
i know when she's kind of scaring me she
used to get a knife and just try to [__]
with me to scare me i know when she's
not trying to get close and this time
she was legitimately she swiped at me
with her whole force and then i started
screaming as soon as i she swiped and i
went oh my god i started screaming jah i
just started screaming like hope to god
my uncle can hear me i'm running around
the coffee table i'm like this i'm
running around the coffee table i'm just
like oh my god oh my god oh my god and
then she just steps on the coffee table
like [__] what the [__] am i gonna do
the coffee table's a foot high she steps
over the coffee table i grab one of the
[__] kitchen chairs i just put it up
and as i put it up she's starting to
swipe at me and then she's like
she does like not a stab but when the
knife's like this and she swiped at me
and she caught my shirt and i like felt
the tug i felt the tug when she caught
my shirt
and i was screaming and that's when i
heard what's going on and pounding on
the door my uncle john
and the door was locked and my sister's
between the door
and i'm like i'm not gonna go unlock the
door she's gonna she's gonna [__]
stab me but when i put my hand on that
lock
how am i gonna block
this is it she's gonna get one in on me
and i don't wanna get stabbed like i'm
not even taking one stab [__] that and
i hear
and then my uncle john
pops it off the frame he hits the door
and the side of the you know the door
frame on the side it's a little cheap
apartment so
i know i'm saying you know the little
store frame on the side it
popped off
and right when he did i dropped the
chair like oh my god he's here and then
right when i did she [__] took this
opportunity upon herself to swipe at me
and when she did that's why i started
like backing up the hallway as fast as i
could and my uncle bear hugged her and
when he bear hugged her he's like put
the [__] knife down he's bear hugging
her she's looking at me like evil and
i'm looking at her like [__] you really
went for it this time huh [__] you and
then my uncle john
uh
is holding her and he's like get the
[__] out of here he's looking at me like
get the [__] out of you right now go to
my house go to my house lock the door
and i
walked i ran past my sister she has no
knife at this point i'm looking at her
and i see my playstation just in pieces
man
and we're thinking like i am not getting
a new one
that's it we're we're poor [__] why'd
you have to step all right [__] you and
then
that was it
and how the [__] did we get on that
topic how do you bounce back from that
i'm now after that happens forever we
share our own
i'm plotting on you wait no that
apartment we had separate rooms that was
the first i think it was the first time
we had separate rooms
yup the apartment on uh hold on hold on
how old are you guys for this exchange
i'm 13 because i was a year younger than
the freshman
so i was 13.
because i i've graduated when i was
turning seven i just turned 17.
15.
no i was 14 i was 14 because football
season was yup because football season
was over and i turned
uh my birthday's in september yep i was
14 because i just i turned 14 in
freshman year you see what i'm saying so
i started senior year at 16 and i turned
17 during senior year
so yeah so i was 14.
my sister was 16. yeah or turning 16
she's a year and a half older than me
and um
yeah that [__] [__] broke my
playstation man i remember that day i
was so sad
[__] jerk but yeah that's my sister
she was super mean how did we get on
that topic
i'm not really sure i'm not sure of the
story that should have oh she's she was
a jerk man
that was the scariest one though
she
i mean the time before that she threw a
knife and it's almost stuck in the wall
right by my [__] face goddamn kill
bill or something like
start throwing [__] she had anger
problems man that's it i think it says
honestly i don't [__] know i don't
[__] know but i know
that was the day
that was the day that i won even though
i almost died i screamed for help that's
the day she never
ever [__] tried to play me again she
never swung on me again she never pushed
me never tried to [__] wrestle me the
ground and punched me and gave me
[__] dead arms and all this [__]
just being a dick for no reas elbow room
was one of her things she would just
start elbowing me in the car
who does that i don't [__] know
anyway
she's nice now
but when we were kids
it was a [__] fight it was me with my
back against the wall all the time
waiting for my sister to [__] me up and
if i did something wrong my mom's gonna
beat my ass too
so
and my dad wasn't there so i was just
alone dude i was so [__] scared as a
kid man always gonna get my ass whooped
and then when i get to school
everybody's making fun of me because i
was fat and that's when i got this loud
i got this
sharp tongue
i i cut you down dude i will [__]
make you cry and cl i've made kids cry
in class by just going in on them and
the whole class is laughing i won't say
names but i mean
this guy this guy i know now
i made him cry in math class
because he tried to make fun of me and
then i turned it into his mom does porn
joke
and he cried
anyway dude second grade i used to get
picked on a lot by these group of kids
and that's what really got my smart
mouth going because i would [__] on them
like i said i was a very mature kid even
when i was younger
even though i was on section like shut
up fool your mom use food stamps and
dude that breaks people down but my mom
used food stamps too
at that time i would just say it's like
i know you do because we do
so
getting made fun of a lot really helped
out it for all you guys can relate
getting made fun of will
strengthen your comedy
heckler stopping skills like you can
[__] on people in four [__] seconds
and then you just keep going that's when
people talk [__] to me on the internet
i don't care i really don't give a [__]
um
so yeah that that's what happens i just
get picked on at home and then go go to
school get picked on and then i started
[__] on people and um i will tell
you one little story this uh this um
indian girl named susan she was
abnormally tall and i was in third grade
and i'm in the gifted classes um you're
watching malcolm in the middle of the
crowboys i was in those classes my whole
from third or fourth grade and up to
high school when i started smoking weed
i realized hey man this is too much work
hey can i get out of these classes and
then they dropped me it was great um
she would make fun of me but i remember
one time she she really burned me and i
remember i go
i kind of like you more now that you
burn me one time i was i missed the day
of school and i was telling this girl i
was i missed a day she's like why were
you uh not here yesterday i go
open my mouth to say something this
[__] susan goes oh he got stuck trying
to put his pants on and i just started
laughing
like you [__] [__] that was funny as
[__] but now it's on now now it's over
i'm gonna [__] on you until you have to
make me stop and i rode the bus with
this [__]
and uh i [__] on her for like three days
and she'd always make fun of me but that
time she made me laugh like i'm not
saying i just picked on her because of
that she always made fun of me that
[__] ugly ass girl and um
i [__] played her so i made fun of
her so hard for three days straight that
her parents came and they called me the
office because she didn't want to come
to school anymore because she was afraid
that i was gonna make fun
you [__] [__] i would literally put
the window click those two tabs put the
window down excuse it your nose is big
as [__] just say second little third
fourth graders talking [__]
but hey susan you brought this on
yourself don't make fun of me a [__]
school year and then when i start
burning you call your parents i felt so
accomplished i felt so [__] i didn't
feel bad i felt nothing but
accomplishment when i knew that her
parents had to drive all the way to the
school
just to [__] have a parent-teacher
conference because this little fat kid
it is it is dude this little [__] was
burning you so bad you had to tell your
mom and dad and she lived in the bomb
bomb has nice ass houses and i remember
thinking why are you making fun of me
[__] you have a nice ass house what do
you got to be mad about
and um
yeah i just fueled everything like oh oh
rich ass [__] big nose ass dude you
got no money to get a [__] nose oh i
was a little piece of [__] but
i don't know i'm glad you turned out so
nice yeah no i was super nice but i was
only mean to the people that were mean
to me yeah you know what i'm saying like
that's interesting though like that's
what it took that's no i got made fun of
all the time dude all the [__] time i
don't speak spanish i was [__] fat
kid
uh i was poor [__]
uh what else i don't know it's [__]
fat i gotta that's what i got all the
time like your family i know [__] say
some other [__] i know i'm fat you [__]
um
but yeah that's what happened i we got
into this long ass me bullying some girl
story i know this is the best with your
sister
but um
yeah that's what happened dude i was
super nice at school until you [__]
with me and then that's how i became
such a smart talking [__] i had
such a smart mouth as a kid man i hope
you realize how psychotic that whole
story i'm trying to picture my kids in
the kitchen well my mom was that
my mom was at work
my sister just started doing drugs
uh she's a [__] [__]
uh she didn't want to admit that she was
fully gay my sister's gay now she's like
but i think she had those problems of
like i don't know if i am and even me as
a kid like no you are i know you are i
can see it i live with you and then i
think when she finally came out she
started being nicer i think that's what
happened
oh well yeah now she can be yourself
yeah i think that's what it was
damn you called was caught the rough end
of that one oh bro no no bob um
i don't i think that was the closest i
ever got to her kill him or her stab i
think so
i don't think there's ever been another
time where she almost stabbed me that
close there's another knife instance but
that one is where i feared for my life
fully
fully feared and then if john didn't
show up it was over so what was that
next morning like i have no idea this
happened all the time she's trying to
[__] do [__] to me all the time
but uh yeah i don't know
that was just a random story this is
some crazy shit's happening dude
i just started to tell you about like i
had like an adopted brother and i'd wake
up and he'd [__] put dirty socks on
my face and be like sacko and run away
and oh for mankind yeah punching his
tailbone and [__] that's funny
yeah that's [__] awesome
that's a funny story marty
i remember i'd get up i'd have to go to
summer school i'd come back i'd pass out
on the couch i'd ride my bike there and
back i'd be getting ready to play
basketball all day he'd be in the same
sock all week oh basketball camp
yeah
yo
hold on marty for those of you that
can't see marty was your stepbrother or
was your adopted brother white
no what not at all no we we look like
straight up
uh wesley and uh woody harrelson back in
the day he wasn't a white guy
i am shocked
the only friends i know that do [__]
like that are white guys
i've never had a mexican friend go hey
wet willy hey i [__] poured water on
you in your sleep
like wait yeah what no because i chill
with all white dudes uh when i after
like 16 and 18 with like a big group of
my homies they're all white dudes
and uh
even they say only white guys do weird
[__] like that man like oh it's the frat
boy mentality the sleepover pranks yo
let's put our balls in this i remember
when someone said that what if i put my
balls in his face and i'm gonna look
down like yo what the [__] did you just
say you're gonna you're gonna molest
this guy and asleep that's what it's all
i'm hearing yo let's put our
dick on him like oh
the [__] wrong with you but sorry for
everybody at home like you're racist
like no i'm just speaking factual terms
yeah no we're breaking down cultural
behavior
as white as i am he was black and he was
doing this that's why i'm shocked right
now marty i that that doesn't line up
with me i've never had a i've had a lot
of black homies man and now oh
[Music]
the one that talked about the balls was
black
homie justin
we had a sleepover with this guy john
and he just put the dog's balls on
john's face and everything this is rape
this is millet this is bestiality this
is weird it's a couple things yeah this
is bestiality weird i don't want to be a
part of it
and uh that you know how i felt i'm
gonna compare it because i sat there and
watched him do it and i didn't wake jon
up because i thought
all these fools are gonna get so mad if
i've ruined the prank and i remember
thinking when i saw he woke up and he
looked at me it was the same feeling
like a full metal jacket when they're
beating piles ass with all those soap
bars and his homie comes looks at him
ah he still hits him that's how i felt
that's how i felt like yo i just lost my
soul to put the dog's balls in his face
that was 12 13.
so i was a child but still i remember
yeah so i take that back justin was
black
and he's the one that came up with the
balls
uh but no just i watched cky i watched
jackass i remember the piss and [__]
pranks and i remember thinking
how
do these how are you friends
i would have beat your [__] ass yeah
i would
your whole night's done if you would
have done that [__] to me and then my
even my homie's like yeah but that's
like white guy [__] they do pranks and
like slap each other in the dick
don't hit me the balls i'm gonna punch
you in the chest what's wrong with you
it's just like cultural [__] it's
different
but thing is both of our instances are n
the both black dudes i know yeah
yeah jesse with my best homie um
your
step your adopted brother is it the same
brother you told me about all the crazy
[__]
yeah yeah i mean it was just me and him
so there yeah there was definitely some
i thought it was your friend oh when you
say your brother that's
i didn't okay gotcha yeah yeah i know
the stories now yeah i guess technically
we would have been cousins but we
basically we grew up calling each other
brothers and [__] you know
this was a basically a wesley woody
harrelson thing got going on mario over
here playing basketball and rapping yeah
[__] duncan
i said duncan he went uh
yeah
back in my day but
yeah wait gotta do it marty's from the
east coast i'm from the west are you
ready did you have a game called butts
up
no
[__]
all right did you have a game where you
throw a racquetball or a tennis ball
against the wall and if you don't get
the right bounce you got to run to the
wall put your hand on it before the
other person throws it yes what'd you
guys call it handball wall ball
wobble
that is such a wack name
this is called wall ball no i'm gonna
i'm gonna look real mad at the camera
and i'm just gonna smack this ball
wall ball
exactly against this wall
wall ball well i mean butts up is kind
of wack too that's kind of it's kind of
a lame name butts up is because
no dude because if you get the ball and
it hits the wall first you got to go put
your [__] butt out you know what i
mean and put against the wall they get
to throw the ball at you is that how you
play
yeah so you guys took it to a whole
nother one oh we took it to the extreme
ball is real clear what's up is like you
i know but wall ball sounds like [__]
yo
this is a podcast they were over your
wall ball wall burgers hey guys this
what happens when you're [__] in
eighth deep with this [__] og i guess
and we're smoking where have we been
smoking today yeah i've been smoking
bowls today it's been a long day so i
had to think back what the [__] i did
today it's been a long [__] day
oh that's soothing rain
but if you're driving i'm sorry to make
you sleepy
um
so yes did you have a game called uh
quarters where you
put your hand you put your knuckles on
the on the table yeah yeah yeah stupid
dumbass game wait let's spread blood
between each other yeah how did these
things pick up before
that you want aids do you want a [__]
blood transfusion
yeah yeah you're getting everything
quarters
the dirty especially when people use
change
we moved on to nickels too
yeah and we moved on to nickels because
they were thicker did you play bloody
knuckles
yeah that was the thing yep yeah i don't
have big knuckles [__] that game yeah um
i had [__] knuckles still i started
hitting the heavy bag
i like the way you saw my
yeah my uh
yeah my knuckles were pretty [__] made
before i started hitting the bag
i didn't
realize yeah you can
you can toughen them up i know i didn't
realize like you look at these ufc
fighters these are blasting that's
different
that's different when you see jaw when i
saw john clap and damn kick a tree over
in that movie when i was a kid that's
when i realized
i cannot beat these people in fights no
matter how big and strong i am there's a
little tie dude that's gonna [__]
cross kick me
knock me straight to sleep ruin my whole
[__] invisalign procedure [__] all my
back teeth up piss me off split my lip
and then he's gonna go yeah i'm four
nine and i just kicked you in the face
i've seen the tie fighters like thai
kickboxers and he's 11 at the same time
he's tony jaw he's an 11 year old tony
jaw they just beat up a group of grown
men nah bro i don't [__] with that [__]
those monks and those tie fighters are
serious they're out there kicking trees
down
i'm not gonna kick a tree down i don't
even want to hit my [__] in with a
[__] razor screwdriver gangster
american is not kicking down a banana
tree the most gangster there you go the
toughest american is like
the toughest american fighter is like
he's pretty good in russia that's what i
was just going to say you know i'm
saying russians are those [__]
are bricks of humans yeah it's cold do
you want to fight like dude
hey it's gold
you know what's on today yo the new
kirby enthusiasm drops today i'm trying
to fight that's america
um
and we were talking about hulk hogan and
proud to be
earlier now i'm over here [__] on
americans i'm only speaking the truth
your local
um
call of duty
partner does not do active push-ups
let's just say that
your average
your average male
under 30 right now
can't do five pull-ups
i can't
and that's one of i'm just speaking the
truth i only got like two friends that
can do pull-ups man and i have some i
have quite a bit of friends pull-ups are
hard as [__] though i feel like i love
that pull-ups are hard
they're unnecessarily hard
yeah
i'm gonna say it right now marnie by
episode 100 i'll do a pull-up
ready by episode 100 on this podcast i
will be able to do a pull-up because i
got my [__] set up about to order this
treadmill i hear marty's doubt in his
silence
these are good goals this is a modest
humble goal
all right i can get behind that listen
we got the we got the
the big industrial shelving units here
got everything here man i used to be a
little [__] monster when i was in
shape before i got a car and started
selling weed
oh man i was in shape because i had to
run everywhere and i had no money to go
buy stuff so i just ran everywhere and
just chilled my friends
sorry guys i had to drink some water
um
so let's get back a little bit on topic
guys
um that was a long rant but
let's get into this current [__] let's
get into what's going on just so you
guys can um
if you're like me let's just put this if
you're like me
you don't know what's going on in the
news
politics
what is it
three to four months ago someone
finally told me the difference between
republican and democrat
i didn't know i just know republicans
are usually the old white racist guys
right am i wrong
as far as i know everybody in politics
is old white race
republicans are usually
in big lifted trucks and they might call
me a [__]
but
i'm only
generalizing i'm not saying everyone
that's what i'm
republicans are what i'm seeing are
usually like the southern states
and they wear maggot heads right that's
usually what i see a republican as your
alter ego where you're like i i want to
live in a neighborhood where they hate
me because i'm not white
yo no my goal in life i told rosie my
goal
listen to me right now guys
bernie mac america listen listen up
america hold on
the boy
sorry i had to do it's episode one
i'm sorry this way
something right
so that's my bernie mac all right here
we go
oh god i'm so off topic started thinking
about bernie mac
sorry i just finished the series again
um
my politics are so [__] somebody just
described what are gave me the
description of republican and the
democrat what the gist when i see most
republicans it's the red right
they wrapped
bloods republicans of blood
and uh they're usually southern white
dudes
with mega hats and i'm only generalizing
because i have no i'm ignorant
remember that if you get mad you're
ignorant because i'm letting you know
i'm [__] ignorant and democrats
are usually like the people
that you see
world star post
is that does that make sense when world
star posts like new check this out this
new senator they're usually democrats
that's how i put it democrats are
people from california right
is that is that how we could say this i
still got the guy gave me the
the precise
description
people are bashing their faces on things
right and i still have no idea because i
don't give a [__]
i don't whoever's being nice and
whoever's for the good of greater good
of people
yeah i'm with it
i have no
i have no knowledge of politics because
i don't i don't dwell i don't uh
fiddle with politics guys i don't know i
just learned the judicial system and
[__] abcd on my tests for high school
and i left i know a lot about art
history uh art history i took like three
years of it because it was an elective
and my teacher was cool
so um
that's politics
so yeah i don't know anything about it
and i'll give you a little story
2000 what
14 when the [__] or 16 when donald trump
became president
i didn't know it was real
it was
a couple days before they did the debate
i didn't know that he was actually
running for president
i saw the [__] online i thought they
were i thought it was a meme
i didn't know that it was real until
right before the debate do you hear what
i'm saying i think i tweeted it is this
real donald trump's running for
president held the people
he's the elect he's uh he got elected to
be one of the [__] candidates and i'm
sitting like yo
is this the same donald trump that we're
all
what so that's me guys i don't pay
attention to the news i don't watch any
of that [__]
it's stressful i don't like to see
horrible things in the news
so i don't really watch the news i
didn't final fall politics i just
thought that it was a meme and then
when they were doing the
votes it was like a day or two before i
ate a shitload of edibles i mean i
man like 2 000 milligrams not a lot like
a shitload but enough to [__] you up so
at 2000 milligrams
i passed out at like six o'clock in the
afternoon i woke up i got on twitter and
it said president donald trump or donald
trump is one blah blah blah
and the first thing that came to my mind
was how long have i been asleep
what the [__] did i just eat am i awake
yet did that guy from the apprentice
just become the president of the united
states
holy [__] and then that's what happened
for the next four years so guys i'm just
letting you know right now
when there's politic talk on here i
better start learning because i don't
know what the [__] going on that's my
uh
full extent but the reason i brought
that up is because joe biden is now
president
i have no idea
anything about the man
i just know he won and i know his uh
the vice president looks like maya
rudolph because she always plays her on
snl and she did a very i'm just gonna
say i didn't know who the lady the vice
president i didn't know who she was
before this presidential campaign maya
rudolph is a good actress she acts just
like this woman dude
there it is snl is my political uh
banking
there you go that's how i find out about
politics
so jim carrey
go ahead i'm just glad the whole shit's
over bro i didn't even pay attention it
could have been over tomorrow and i
didn't know it was over did you just put
up maya angelou on the screen
oh my rudolph okay there you go
you did click maya angelou first right
yep okay i'm not tripping
i was talking about how she plays such a
good um
what's her name camilla harris right
yeah vice president yo i really really
gotta learn these things because
me asking who vice president was just
made me disappointed in myself you're
gonna want yeah there's a couple key
terms in this yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
need to learn this stuff because
at least in school i knew who all these
people were because he had to after
school and i just started going into the
packs
and selling [__] i don't [__] know or
care who the president was back then i
don't give a [__] when you're
when you're trying to make [__] money
you don't care who the president is when
you're poor what the [__] or when you
don't trust the whole system oh yeah i
think it was a drug deal you think i'm
like yo i'm voting [__] no i'm not
voting
yo the first time i ever tried to vote
dude
i got a break on my pizza job i was
selling weed to gotta break up my pizza
job smoked a bowl in the way of the
voting section him or said
walked up waited in line did it all and
they go uh you need to vote in your side
of town this is what the [__] told me
you need to vote in your side of town in
your jurisdiction and i thought i just
want to vote i'm on my lunch break yeah
you're in the wrong side of town and
when she said you're in the wrong side
of town i thought
i'm not voting i am not driving all the
way to my shitty part of the town
on my lunch break and i felt so played
that i actually tried to contribute and
i got [__]
get out of here that's exactly what they
did to me so yeah for the past eight
minutes i've been showing you my
ignorance um maybe i'll learn maybe i'll
learn some [__] cuz uh i have no idea
what i'm talking about but that could
change
that could change so
that's the current event
and like we said earlier packers are out
bills are out that's the other current
event patrick mahomes has a 503 million
dollar [__] contract
i just want to high five that guy i just
want to high five him so hard good
good commercial [__] in every
commercial but good job [__]
get that money from these fools
yes
for tom brady i love you [__] you tom
brady you're always [__] up
everyone's plans if you're not a
patriots fan [__] you because man
this is one of those things that's like
you're so good
just
bro take a vacation
just take a [__] vacation stop
ruining everyone here because you're
ruining everyone's year every year but
like i said if you're a patriots fan
that's cool but i'm not a [__]
patriots fan but it's it's it's cool man
i'm i'm happy that i grew up in the tom
brady era even though even though tom
brady might be a cheetah we're still
going to kick some cougar ass
um
yeah he's a cheese he's a cheater she's
still good
you can't fake throwing that
[__] ball
that [__] is a badass to go down
to this to tampa go to tampa and go
straight back you
monster who did you pay
who did you pay because
sometimes i don't believe it sometimes
i'm like yo that call
that call look bought
yeah i don't know i don't know what it
is sometimes it's like yo
are you guys friends
because i believe i wouldn't put it best
yet anyway that's my uh football rant
because [__] tom brady's in the super
bowl again
and mahomes they're gonna smash tampa
bay doesn't have a chance
uh my patreon homes and uh was it tyree
kill
and travis kelsey that team that little
package is unstoppable try yeah try to
[__] stop it come on man not
happening i'm so i'm so like all i know
is the bills i was with this dude i was
with travis kelsey all day didn't even
know who he was or what to do oh when
you failed the other day
he's a big [__] yeah yeah he's
giant yeah he's a bad ass and then he
absolutely destroyed us all game long on
sunday i forgot so marty didn't mention
it we did a practice episode last week
guys so we can like run the sound and
everything and then right after this
full had a
shoot the next morning
and he text me because we were talking i
wonder what it's going to be he has a
shoot with this company he works with
and he knows it's t-mobile commercial
right that's all he knows oh no you
didn't know his t-mobile commercial all
he knows is it's a commercial but he's
done a t-mobile commercial before with
that company so we were like oh it might
be a t-mobile commercial he doesn't text
me or nothing because marty gets up at
[__] five in the morning so he was
already doing his thing he didn't text
me because he was on his he was working
and i just look on instagram and there's
marty filming [__] gwen stefani and
it's a super bowl commercial you monster
this full has filmed two super bowl
commercials in the past month wait four
yeah because the the first
shoot with anthony anderson was three
different uh commercials
oh okay yeah you're right you're right
you're right
and then you did the espn show
yo
there's so much cool [__] going on man
so much cool [__]
it's very cool this fool's having a
a good year a good past couple months
and then the bill's lost and conor
mcgregor got his ass knocked out but
that's okay
that's all right take those on the chest
yeah
that's okay podcast is launched i'm
feeling okay yeah we're good you know
i got nothing to complain about man so
i'm just happy to be here i'm happy that
we're finally
we're finally doing it we've been
talking about this for a year just
trying to set it up and here it is
you know what i'm saying it's just uh
it's very
i don't even know how to put it
yeah i just said it a story time you
know be fun a podcast i just said that
[__] randomly
and then i started thinking about it
more and more and more and thinking
there's so many people watching our
youtube channel for the stories
all it is is talking
except in the stories i'm not um uh
because i get to edit this but here [__]
it episode one i got some errs and eyes
all right and be all right and yeah yeah
i'm looking at a notes all right if
you're wondering what i'm look i don't
got no weed hey hussy can you possibly
roll a joint
thank you
yes i should just roll like five joints
before i start these um
well we're learning it's a learning
process but
i have
a story i want to tell you guys
because
it's just fun
it's a fun story
it's really not fun it's just kind of
[__] up but
it's
fun for me to think about it and go
yeah that that's real that's what
happened
most people hear my stories they're like
are you okay did you have to go to
therapy like no i have to go to therapy
the [__] you talking about it just
happened i'm here now
uh which which story should i tell
should i marty you pick should we go
weed selling should we go almost dying
should we go gangbangers what should we
do i'm from the land of gangbangers meth
and cps paperwork man i feel like we've
kind of touched on these all right we
have we have but not in this episode
this is our first episode okay yeah yeah
i'm saying we did a test run you you got
the near death experiences with the the
there's so much [__] there's there's
there's so much but i just wanted to
talk about it because there's a like i
said there's gonna be a lot of people
that just saw this picture on spotify
and click like what the [__] is this
this is for you guys for all the other
fans they probably heard they probably
heard this
but um
let's go with uh
let's go with the good old you know what
let me tell these guys real quick let me
tell you guys about the weirdest [__]
weed dealer i ever had in my entire life
all right let's just go because i've had
some awesome awesome ones i've had some
movies
the [__] that people don't post on the
internet is so much more wild than the
[__] that people [__] film the stuff
that doesn't get filmed you guys won't
you wouldn't even believe it if i
you wouldn't believe it unless i filmed
it some of the [__] the lifestyles i all
my friends used to be drug dealers i've
seen some crazy [__] i've seen a lot of
drugs seen a lot of money seen a lot of
guns
and everybody i've ever [__] with just
smiling everybody's so happy i don't
like drug dealers that i have to be like
oh do i need a gun to go to this guy's
house
no my friends with the guns they just i
just have cool guns
do you see what i'm saying so i was
never really like in danger because i
never put myself in that position
never never in life the reason is i
always tell my girlfriend
um like i said earlier i'm the cable guy
i grew up on movies that's how my
babysitter i watch movies
i've learned all my life lessons from
watching movies guys everything i've
ever learned is from movies
um shows things i remember
like uh
watching where i'm walking i walk around
alleys i don't go by doorways i don't
go into places unless i have a way out
it's because of good fellas when robert
de niro is telling uh karen uh
the wife hey go down there there's some
dresses yeah don't go
in no go in when he's doing that
they're moving plastic yeah all bad i
remember i was about probably six or
seven when i watched that
and i'm watching it and i'm sitting
there
watching it and assessing like
he's gonna kill you and wrap you in
plastic huh and then i thought she's
smart she ran right away right back to
the thing if i'm ever in it and that's
how i learned that lesson like don't
walk by alleys you walk around you don't
walk into places you don't know where
the [__] you're at you don't walk into
places you can't get right out
immediately
you know like that's how i always learn
that [__] so
growing up
movies that was it
so
let's i want to tell you guys about
i don't even know why the [__] i brought
that up but
i'm gonna tell you guys about uh
the weirdest drug dealer i ever had in
my life oh yeah the reason i brought it
up i've seen some crazy crazy
unbelievable things
because of people i know
i used to sell massive amounts of weeds
so huh
come on man you get 100 packs for people
there's it's a lot of wheat it doesn't
sound like a lot of weed to some people
that are let's say 100 pounds who gives
a [__] bro
10 bah i don't care i'm just saying to
me as a kid when i was broke seeing that
much weed
yeah
i would hope
well
to my friends a hundred pounds is like
oh that's my 10 o'clock appointment you
know like i have friends that are
straight businessman with this weed and
if they weren't selling weed they could
be working on any big giant fortune 500
company
do you know that that you guys know
those people oh if you weren't into this
you'd be killing it in this if you
didn't grow up like this oh you'd be the
man over here if i wasn't doing weed
marketing and all this other crazy [__]
i'd probably work for some big company
because the marketing [__] we do and the
campaigns we do
get crazy ass numbers and impressions so
if we weren't into the we would be doing
something else
you see what i'm saying so
a lot of the drug dealer homies i know i
mean just
i've never seen people make so much
money in my entire i've never seen three
or four hundred thousand dollars just be
made in a couple minutes
and my friend like oh yeah just put it
right there and not give a [__] because
that's just his appointment in the
morning if was going to do it four more
times today and to them
it's nothing so 50 grand like
okay i don't care that to me like 50
grand is a lot to somebody working at
[__] mcdonald's still like i was 50
grand the world so there's levels you
saw him saying so when it comes to these
things you'd have to almost film it for
people to believe it because it's
unfucking real
so i'm gonna tell you about
not those drug dealers though we have
more episodes guys i'll talk i'll talk
about all these guys uh let's call this
guy dan because
i talked about this on a story time
like i said earlier when john
disappeared i was weedless i had no
connect anymore because john was the
kinect i didn't bother to keep my
relationship with anybody else i got
weed from
because john was the man so he
disappeared for about a month and a half
i had no we connect i was buying zips
from people i
sold weed to
you know it's bad when you're hitting up
people that hit you up for pounds and go
hey man you had a couple zips
you know it's getting rough
so
my friend shane introduced me to a guy
called dan a guy named dan
and i'm gonna just i want you guys to
pretend you're in my [__] brain and
you're looking through my eyes if you're
if you were in a car
here we go book on tape let's get
i want you guys to imagine everything
i go meet dan
um uh that he opens the door
regular looking kind of chunky guy he
looks like uh the guy from shawn of the
dead the fat dude looks just like that
[__] guy even with the beard stubble
all that [__]
so i walk in and dan lets me in with
shane shane's introducing me to dan he
lives in merced in a nice house and back
and i was like 18. like damn this was
got a nice ass [__] hell he's like 25
[__] yeah what's he do and i'm like
what's he doing you're picking up weed
so this is me talking to myself in my
head right i'm burnt so i'm just talking
to myself i walk in two steps and i just
smell
like
body odor
bad like
wet body secretions in the air like
nasty not [__]
like someone stinks like they don't wash
yourself what body secretions in the air
is the most important thing you could
almost taste that [__] like it could
stick to your clothes type of smell you
guys
you know what i'm talking about
so i walk in
i get two steps i smell it i get three
steps in i look to the right and there's
a woman right there in a hospital bed
and shh
she
i'm i'm big my grandma dolores she was
big too right
i've never seen anybody that big before
i've never seen a bird not only in
movies
like what's eating gilbert grape [__]
like that
never seen somebody that size
she was such a nice [__] lady i mean
oh i was going over there for months
like five or six months and all every
day re-up get more get more get more we
get more weeks he was taxing me i'll get
to that later
such a nice such a nice woman but she
was probably like seven seven hundred
pounds or something she took up the
whole hospital bed she had um
breathing tubes in
and she was like oh hello she was like
very soft like oh hi she was very cool
and i said oh hello and she's like oh
hello and she had a tv right there i
walked by her so that was his mom
and i mean i assume i assume it's his
mom
and i walk in
to the toward the kitchen area and home
it stinks bro it smells violent and i
walk in and there's like two or three
kids dirty as [__] you know what i mean
like when you go to walmart you just
want to beat the [__] out of a parent
because your kids are so dirty
that's how dirty these kids were but you
know they're in diapers like three so
you know they're kids they're kids so
i'm not thinking anything of them like
okay you're dirty but you're in your
house but i noticed how dirty these
[__] kids were like cps dirty you
know what i'm saying
like you're cleaning a [__] chimney
in the 40s and
i see these kids that automatically
think oh man are these your kids are you
one of these [__] dads
and i look i look past the kids and
there's the most [__] weed i have
seen in a long time i mean
to that point i've seen 100 packs before
but
top shelf i've seen 100 pack of outdoors
but the top shelf has probably had like
60 or 70
perfect pounds
i mean you could see the purple through
the bag you can see the green that's
back when sour diesels were popping
a lot of purples
and uh
joint throw thank you
oh thank you
and um
carry package
thank you
and i see all the packs and uh
everything just goes away oh [__] man
these kids all these kids aren't dirty
and i look at the packs like yeah what's
up with these pounds then he tells me
the price and i just wanted to fight him
because it was so expensive
and the house stunk
and his dad comes in from the back room
and his dad's a big dude he's like don
vito from uh
bam from jackass he's like don vito size
looks like him just kind of like regular
fat dude walks in but he's like three or
four hundred pounds he's not he's not as
big as the mom
and uh the only reason i'm saying this
guys and even talking about how big they
were is because it all
is gonna be
it all comes together all right here we
go
we go into the back room because he's
like you wanna try this weed out they
don't smoke in the living room because
the kids are right there and
automatically my good thank you for not
just blowing smoking your dirty ass
kid's face so we go in the back room he
has a bong right there and there is a
[__] dude in there
straight up south park when they talk
about gamers this fool's gaming
and dan goes yo slim let me see your
bong he called his brother it's his
little brother slim slim was
probably about 500 pounds maybe but that
[__] was rocking it no shirt no
shoes just shorts
hell of soda bottles and cans in that
room
oh my god this man had so many [__]
cans and bottles in that room playing
games and he just went get out of my
room
he had a beard he wasn't a child he's
like [__] 25. he had a beard get out
of my room dad shut the [__] up i give
you weed shut the [__] up and he just
went right back to his game
like he punked his little brother and he
was being so weird and this is my first
impression guys this is my first time in
this guy's house we take a ball we take
a bomb rip
and i like
cup my lip
on the bong so i don't put my lips on
the bong because this [__] stunk
like [__] he was dirty
it was just like oh man
get me out of this motherfucker's room
it stinks in here and then we go back in
the living room and like that's where
the smell was coming from oh my god it
was all the way from your back room holy
[__] so long story short
we get the packs uh he
completely molests me on the [__]
price i'm sorry that took so long to say
he molested me on the price guys okay he
raped my pockets
and i paid
i think i paid i think it was all 1100
bucks for the queue
almost 300 bucks an ounce i feel like
anyway i paid it i [__] paid it dude
and i get the weed i'm like yo this
sweets [__] fire i'll be back
tomorrow and that's how i started
talking to his mom more she's a real
nice lady this is not the weird part
guys when he was weighing my weed out
he for those of you watching on youtube
he's looking down here's the scale
here's the packs he's weighing out my qp
and he just
trolls
one long string of drool just
and i can see it break his lip and go
and start stretching like the black
stuff from ferngully and it starts
stretching and i'm looking at it and
imagine me like zooming in with my eyes
like
don't fall in the way please
and i see the string of spit it goes
down and it goes splash touches his
stomach and it hooks onto his stomach so
i'm like yeah
i just didn't want you to drool inside
my [__] weed and then i thought
what's wrong with him that he's just
drooling we're having a conversation the
man's just sitting there drooling
first impression super stinky he's
drooling his kids are dirty his
brother's gross
so
this is not why i brought him up guys
that's a regular dirty ass dude right
regular guy regular dude
this is where
this is why i brought him up okay so
remember oh yeah i forgot to mention
like oh yeah i told you dan he's kind of
out of shape he's like the guy from sean
on the dead he's like my size but he's
got a [__] gut he's pretty [__]
fat he definitely can't touch his toes
and um
this [__]
tells me he we come over to get some
zips because his homies like a mile away
and i just pulled up some random garage
and i thought all right shane's with me
it's all shames with me [__] yeah it's
fine because i don't go to random
[__] spots i'm not trying to get
robbed or [__] held captive
anyway
they opened the garage door it's a
mexican dude i'm like oh hell not full
school's got long socks on why am i here
and then dan's there
and i'm like all right dan's a white
dude by the way
um they're in there working out
with like weights and [__] and dan's all
sweaty i'm like whoa dan you could move
so maybe you can't touch your toes like
maybe you can and uh
we start talking about the weed and we i
don't know how we get into the topic
guys you know we dealers he just starts
talking and he goes i'm quoting you yeah
i was tr
i was trained by a native american he
was in vietnam he showed me hand-to-hand
combat and me i'm i'm fairly new to dan
so i'm not trying to just bust up
laughing his [__] face because even
though even me i'm like your big ass
ain't doing no hand-to-hand combat you
[__] lying piece of [__] like you're
bigger than i am full and i am not doing
handheld going shut the [__] up
the way he said it yeah he's native
american like four you might as well put
a spotlight on you you [__] actor
this is not right this isn't fake
and he goes yeah he used to put me
against the wall and punch me as hard as
he could until i started blocking all
the punches he said the the indian man
would go back against the wall and he'd
have dan punch him and he said the guy
would block every punch like a [__]
ninja just block and break down the arms
like break it down move it
and i'm sitting there like yo give me my
weed
that's what i'm trying to telepathically
to look at shane like
you can you tell your friend to stop
lying just give me the weed i'm i have
money i just want to buy a weed and get
out of here
and i'm looking at shane and shane kind
of does this one to me
while dan's not looking like you know
this phone's lying his ass off and i'm
looking at shane we both like okay we
both establish line okay let's listen
and i'm like oh really you're back
against the wall crazy so how much is
the wheat i'm just trying to get out of
there and he goes no man he taught me
for years like i bet you guys couldn't
even land a punch on me and i tell him
oh man i don't know man
yeah i don't want to punch you and he
goes no no i bet you couldn't land a
punch on me he tried chained me for
years and i go yeah dude i probably
couldn't i don't know how to fight i'm
just trying to get i'm just trying to
get out of there i don't want to start
fighting you know what i'm saying he
goes nah hell no you guys trying to land
a punch on me and shane looks at him
like
i'm good so we and shane now establish
that we both don't want to fight dan in
the garage so
let me let this joint he has some
napoleon dynamite this is real this is
real and it gets better okay
so
he goes nah man i'm putting my back
against the wall i bet you can't hit me
go i don't i don't want to do it man i
really don't shay because i'm good
because i will give you an ounce right
no no no i will give you both an ounce
right now if you can hit me
i look at shane like did he just say
i'll give you 300 dollars if you can hit
me because that's all i heard an ounce
to 300 because you're taxing me yeah
i'll take that [__] deal and uh shane
he stan he has his back against wall and
shane like
like half ass
you blocked it like you know what i mean
i just
uh
oh got me because no i want you guys to
really try to hit me that's because i
want you to really try to hit me try to
hit me in the face i go bro i'm not
trying to hit you in the face i will
give you guys two zips right now if you
can land anything on me land a finger on
me and i will give you guys two ounces i
like a shameless all hail he goes
all right can we go at the same time and
i look at shane like you smart
[__] and he goes yep i don't
care both you at the same time
guys
let me explain to you what the [__] i
witnessed
e honda was in this man's heart
thousand hand slap
that's this guy so
i do this guys i'm looking at his face
right
and i do this
and try to trick him i pretend to go for
his face i try to punch him with my left
hand in the stomach this [__]
does this
i mean breaks my [__] just
smacks me in the wrist so violently hard
and fast that you know when you get that
coal feeling in your bone where you
smack your bone hard
that's what i got instantly he blocked
shane's hand and me and shane looked at
him like
what the [__] okay maybe you got lucky
and i'm thinking two sips huh and i
start going [__] fast like trying to
just just get a finger on this man's
butt remember his backs against the wall
he's just blocking us
shane is punching with his two hands
like a human i'm a human i got two
[__] hands too sam i mean uh dan he's
got [__] 35 hands apparently this
[__]
is
shark eyes
rolled back all black and he's just
doing this [__] he honda breaking
and slapping my [__] hands away two
hands blocking them just doing this
looking straight
and i'm just in disbelief like there's
no way this is real this [__]
serious
i didn't land one finger on him no he
ended up giving us a couple nugs just
like to do it
i didn't land a finger on him shane
didn't land one [__] finger on him
guys
when this man says he was trained by a
[__] native american soldier he was
not kidding i thought this [__]
drooling ass stinky dan i thought
drooling stinky dan was a nasty ass drug
dealer
no
not at all this man was a killer i
didn't realize that drooling as high as
dan could really move like that he was
i've never seen anybody in my life do
that never seen anybody move faster in
person i've seen bruce lee movies but
this was in person all right
not done then he showed me i can disable
and at this point me and shane were like
yo
what else did you learn like we were
like no way no [__] way this is real
we end up buying the wheat anyway but
like i said he gave us a couple nugs
actually we smoked it together and
so we're like we're hooked we both now
look at dan as a different person like
no way are you serious can we hang out
with you can we chill for a little bit
like we're like astonished and he says
yeah you want to see how to disable a
person's arm and uh
this [__]
he goes it kind of hurts i told him i
don't want to do that man he's like i'll
give you a couple more nugs all right so
i said all right and this [__]
he goes try to punch me in the face go
i'm not trying to punch you in the face
because i'll block it don't worry i'm
like yeah that's true you will block it
i go to punch him in the [__] face
and this full
smacks me and the inner part of my
like armpit but not of the armpit he
hits me so fast with his knuckle and
then my arm just did this
shut off i'm my brain
fully functional i'm trying to tell it
to move my arm my arm won't move
never felt like that my life i've never
been so like
what the [__] is going on like my arm
would not move he goes don't worry go
back about 30 40 seconds and he's
telling me these things like yo
did you steal all this we can kill
somebody to get it because you're an
assassin you shut my arm off shut my arm
off showed me and shane that day how to
shut someone's arm off
for the next five months that's all we
did when we got drunk like yo you want
me to show you how i could you know shed
your arm and nobody's gonna say yeah
yeah let's do it i had to convince him
like no come on it's real and then
showing everybody everybody thought we
were [__] tripping until we did it
and that was like a new party trick yo
you want me to [__] up your nervous
system and that's exactly what happened
and then me and my girlfriend are
watching damn cobra car the other day
and ralph macchio gets his [__] arm
disabled that's exactly exactly what
stinky dan did to me guys so
this drug deal and then about five
months of going to him i found a better
connect that's really what happened i
found a better connect that wasn't
taxing the [__] out of me and i never
called dan again
that was it
god damn that was dan the fastest fat
guy i've ever seen i mean
marty
i've never seen a ufc fighter move like
that maybe veto bell for it
was he [__] with you bro he was so
psychotic [__] fast he had his back
against the wall he wasn't even looking
at us in the eyes and he was just
blocking things like he was
like he was had time to see it go
uh no no let me get this one first
uh it was astonishing dude and i'm just
happy that shane was there because
i have a witness
i have a witness that somebody else was
there because if it's just me nobody's
gonna believe me no one ever [__]
believe that i wouldn't believe you i
don't believe you if you told me i saw
it happen it sounds like the plot
i saw happy bro he really did that [__]
and the whole time in my head i'm
doubting like you stink and you're a
liar that's all like you're thinking
it's like
express meets the matrix dude he did you
know what's kind of funny he kind of
does look like danny mcbride and [__]
pineapple express except with a beard
he's that shape for sure
but yeah dude i've never seen anybody
move that fast my whole [__] life and
uh
that was dan my weed dealer when i was
19 20.
yeah about 19.
crazy [__] man it was uh fun times
barty
do you have any crazy drug dealer
stories from buffalo
i'm sure i probably do but my stories
don't add up to yours whatsoever hey man
i just want to hear east coast [__] the
only east coast like i said the only
knowledge i have the east coast is
seinfeld and home alone too
that's that's it and the wire but that's
in [__] baltimore that's not even in
new york
that's my east coast dude all movies if
you're from new york you know you gotta
talk like this and if you don't we don't
know where you're from
because i'm from i'm from a different
part of america where we're all ignorant
as [__] in california and everybody
talks like i do
and if you don't you're probably from
another state
yeah all my weird stories are just
playing cat and mouse with these cops
through the
sides oh yo can i i'm gonna tell i'm
gonna tell everybody marty grew up in uh
like like a pretty
drug
traffic area and listen to this do you
want to hear the funniest thing ever
marty used to get pulled over a lot in
the area he lived in because he was
white and they thought he was buying
drugs because white people only come
over there to buy drugs so marty was
getting [__] discriminated against
because his skin color because i thought
he was buying drugs if that's not the
funniest [__] then i thought that was
funny
that's so funny the white supremacist
taught me spanish you got pulled over in
the drug area because you're white
do you get pulled over and discriminated
against because you're white is the
money it would stalk me that's the thing
dude watch me pump gas and then covertly
parallel yeah he definitely don't live
over here like yo i just literally left
my house right there
mari's only white dude over there that's
why
i love that that is the funniest [__]
thing ever man i've lived here for eight
years and never been pulled over not
once not once yep because you uh you
rock the straight bill hat you look like
you wear rvca
that's possible
i don't i don't know i thought oh you
rock o'neill because how lucky that
that's your [__] name you get a rock
or deal
a sponsored yeah i got it i got a rich
dad i got a rich dad
um real quick guys
ad read number two this video is
sponsored by
us once again
once again this video is sponsored by us
um exclusively you can go right now to
doublezil.com and see us
sponsoring this [__] sponsoring this
[__]
my bank account
um
yeah that's our ad read we don't have
any sponsors so we're not doing that yet
we're
just wanted to get this first episode
out to you guys it's been long a long
wait we just wanted to talk we are at
two hours
exactly
we've been talking for two hours wow
if you've been sticking around the whole
time [__] thank you
sorry excuse me
you stuck around this long thank you so
much that's [__] awesome
two hours nice guys episode one long
awaited for all the story times all the
[__] weed reviews smoking 40 gram
joints and
5 000 milligram challenges and smoking
grams of hash
why
because it's awesome
i always get that question dude i always
get that question why do you smoke so
much weed because i did the math the
other day it's kind of sad
uh if i smoke
if i s
if i smoke
uh we were almost an ounce a day-ish
and it drops like a little less less
than a half
if we're smoking like a qp ish a week
when we were smoking heavy
that's a pound you know that's 12 pounds
a year-ish maybe more because we do the
wii challenges and you know reviews
so for the past i've been smoking a week
for [__] 15 years at least but
smoking heavy like that probably like
eight eight years nine years
we're over 100 pounds of weed
that's [__] insane
it's like i smoked 100 pounds of weed
you're telling me i spent at least two
hundred thousand dollars on weed in the
past eight years
oh my god
no
you stupid [__] that's how i
feel but um
the
through all that yeah business though at
least you at least you were enterprising
throughout that yeah that's just it's
just crazy to say it like you spent at
least 200 bands on weeds this past
decade
more
that's how i feel like it's just a head
stash weed
just to smoke this is not selling we
we're just smoking weed
um
so yeah for everyone i know i know
there's a couple names out there that uh
people been here the longest i've i mean
people been here since the beginning
when i first started instagram it's so
crazy to see it
like i always say like you guys watch me
grow up on camera i was a little i was a
i was a child basically when i started
doing this [__] i'm still a kid i'm
still a [__] kid but
it's just weird it's like yo it's been
nine almost nine years that's a long
time it's a long time to be doing
something it's a long time to be doing
and i don't even remember which years
what i just know by picture like oh that
was this year at this event
because the [__] up part about it is
that's how long it takes to get good at
something
dude we've only been talking the camera
for a year and a half
like i did not talk on camera whatsoever
until
we started doing youtube
yeah it's just scary i was just talking
about the other day when i did my first
hosting event yo i stood on the side of
the stage i threw [__] out i didn't want
to get on the stage i didn't touch a
microphone do nothing i do not like
talking in front of people and then when
i realized like yo just talk you [__]
[__] and yeah now i'm fine now i'll
talk in front of a million people don't
give a [__]
we have a privilege to fight
you i've been watching the office for
nine years straight bro everything is a
[__] office reference to me it's so
sad mark do you watch office
wait no you're busy and you're [__]
seriously never mind yeah i'll say never
mind you have responsibilities and [__]
you're watching the office at 12 o'clock
at night swimming weed
um
but yes
the reason like i said sorry it's a long
rant it's yo this should be called
ranting i'm going to say that again i'm
going to do a uh
a segment go all right guys for the next
30 minutes i'm going to rant and forget
about what the [__] i was talking about
and ask you what the [__] is it talking
about you guys ready to go that's what
the whole rant's going gonna be called
um
the reason i smoke so much weed that's
what it was the reason i smoke so much
weed and people ask me this all the time
and some people call me an [__] but i
don't [__] care
the reason i smoke so much weed is
because when i was younger and it was
hard to get weed
and i was broke as [__] all i wanted was
like
two joints
enough money to go buy some food and i
can chill
but it was one of the other
you guys
for you relating to me you know the pain
of
we can get one swisher
a ten sack we can both buy two
mcchickens we can go to the store and
get one two liter
you know you're mapping out what's 15
can get you
yeah you don't understand that pain
i don't there barely being any weed to
be had period in the whole town that's
different man you're on the [__] east
coast man that's a whole nother story
all right
so it's different man those are
yeah
you might end up on an adventure yeah
when i moved to oregon oh it was an
adventure trying to get weed
when you don't know the people in town
and i don't like talking to strangers
yeah you're probably not gonna find any
weed man
um yeah no i could i could see i could
see why you're talking about on the east
coast but i mean more of like
the times where i was just sitting there
watching half bait because i wanted to
watch people smoke weed because i love
that movie when i didn't have any weed
and thinking
14 year old me like one day i'm gonna
have
a job where i can do what i want and i'm
gonna smoke as much weed as i want and
now that time has come and i take full
advantage of it because when i was
younger i didn't think it was gonna
happen
i just hoped for it and now that it's
here yeah i'm smoking the joint
oh you guys want to do that
yeah take a dab why [__] not that's
how i feel why not this is what i've
always wanted to do and i might as well
take full advantage of it while i can so
that's why i smoked so much wheat for
the nights that i didn't have any weed
or money and i was just sitting there
bored
couldn't find it stuck in my grandma's
in the country
yeah that's why
horrible
yeah horrible how many times i've
searched yo you guys know when you're a
teenager and you're bored and you like
get your grandma's or your aunts or
something and you search the whole house
like there's got to be something in this
house for me to do there's got to be
like
oh here's my aunt's old stash box with
some [__] cocaine in it i mean i
found coke in a
jewelry box and i don't know who's
whose box it was found coke
i was
17 in the bottom of a box and it was
green felt and it was all like
rocks and rubbed into the felt so i
couldn't do it and i wasn't sure if it
was actually coke so i didn't want to
snort it but it was definitely coke we
were in texas for like
two and a half months
no weed at all oh god
i found a nugget behind the toaster oven
you're [__]
your voice your voice right now
i've found
it was like a nirvana like walking
through the desert wait wait wait you
found it behind your own toaster oven
you were in a rental it was a fully so
somebody left it yes oh my chance oh
that's bomb shock coincidence bomb
yeah it was amazing that's cool when we
were in cancun and we got stuck because
our plane
doesn't work
all right that's what they said this
plane's not working and we went back to
the uh
airport after the airport was closed
because we're on the tarmac for [__]
four hours it was closed i don't speak
spanish i can't read the signs it took
me so long to find my way back to the
[__] to the right line because it was
empty there's nobody there and there was
power outages because it was [__] hot
so it's going pitch black at night i'm
stuck i have nowhere to go because my
vacation's over
and we met
two people that happened to be from
[__] van nuys
two dudes uh i mean
a couple a chick and a dude the guy had
his own vape pen that he makes from his
own company he happened to have a vape
in
i had no weed i hit that [__] like four
times and got high as [__] off it and
you saved like whoever you are you saved
my ass remember that rosie we were
standing in line in the line remember
this is a plane full of people that now
have from the resort that now don't have
a resort room so they put us in a hotel
in the really bad part of cancun as
we're driving there i'm looking at rosie
like
i don't like this there's
rubble
right here on the ground and i when i
said there's rubble there was broken
walls of buildings just on the ground
with the [__] wire
going through the brick and [__] the
concrete and it was just exposed
and i looked around like this is some
[__] [__] and then i saw
people ride by screaming out of a car
and then the cops came by with a bunch
of guns and i look at rose like you know
get the [__] am [__] vegan what am i
going to eat we ate pringles
hella pringles and a and a lemonade
a shitty ass lemonade but it was dumb
cheap and i can't remember how much is
it
a dollar like wait i'm doing the math
like
i'm gonna give you a dollar as a tip
i went back out of here i was tipping i
didn't know at the resort i was
everybody's best friend i kept tipping
everybody and not remembering yo
american money is way more
valuable you just hit that man like 300
like
bro that's fine then he's gonna like me
and he's gonna be nice to me so i'm
gonna tip him again i was tipping people
like 20 bucks 15 bucks just for doing
miscellaneous oh thanks man just because
i was on vacation and then i found out
the ratio
and that that's why they were doing all
this [__]
every time oh don't say that
no no
hey man i don't do the f i didn't light
him on fire that one wasn't me
that [__] replacing my head every time i
think about that going back to me like
yo that guy scared me scared the [__]
out of me but no my whole family's from
like mexico they always go i'm the only
one that's never gone
they always go to the uh they have
uh property in acapulco that's where my
grandma's from and uh
my whole family goes melissa's my little
brother everybody i'm just the only one
that's not gone
because i ain't trying to go to a
country you can't get high at i'm cool
man i want to stay in [__] l.a where
i can smoke [__] weed i can be
california smoke weed i even i don't
even go to the midwest you can't smoke
weed there so
i'm happy here you guys are archaic
yeah like yo
i don't even speak spanish man i'm gonna
get lost out there
but i do i would like to go i've never
seen where my grandma's from that'd be
sick
but uh my grandpa's from the jungle out
there
jungle of mexico
but uh
dude
straight up guys this is first episode
this is a ranty
we're talking about random [__] now i
see i almost
there's so many stories my grandpa my
mexican has grandpa
if you guys know old mexican people they
think they can fix everything with
nothing
i was able to tell a story where you try
to fix help me fix my car but
we should wrap this up it's already over
two hours in and i don't want to go
another 35 minutes and just for you guys
to go yo grandpa's dumb like no he's
he's really smart he just
ah yeah he's dumb
i don't want to do that so
no my grandpa's smart as [__] that full
made money off of nothing
so he's smart but just when he fix his
stuff sometime like yo grandpa that is
not how that happens even i know you
don't do that no no no
all mexican old people
oh [__] all right
then he lately goes ah how do you say it
uh something and he says it in english
oh that's right
you know i don't speak spanish
i'm the only one my family doesn't speak
spanish no lie
about it
only one the only one my sister speaks
spanish now too i'm the only one my
little brothers and sisters when they
used to get mad at me they would look at
their
my stepmom and say whatever happened in
spanish so i wouldn't know what they
were saying so they could lie like yeah
thomas said this i'm like
you [__] no i didn't i'm like i
don't care you know i'm an adult right
you can't tell on me they didn't get
that until they got older they always
start telling like mitch i have my own
house i'm just gonna leave
um see we can't be talking i'll just
rant it's been another three [__]
minutes i can't do this guys we gotta
wrap this [__] up
um
episode one so just bear with me i'm
gonna turn my neck this way to look at
my nose real quick uh
yeah there we go okay there we go it
just says outro
just wrap it up
wrap it up wrap it up b
i love this chapel show
um
yeah well she's got to stop before we
start getting into the spell show
moments
i can't when that [__] show came out
it took over my whole school
i mean the next day was just a
free-for-all of
what
okay loudest thing in the [__] planet
you've ever heard and i was in football
so we're all doing weights and all you
hear is people
screaming like lil jon
and i hadn't seen the episode yet
because i missed it
you remember that as a kid man
everybody no i'm saying when everybody
watched a show and you missed it
and you come to school and everybody's
talking about it like
hey could you guys stop talking about
it's not all so you don't ruin it uh no
you should have [__] been there like
oh damn not to mention dvr
oh back then dude new malcolm in the
middle you guys didn't see what happened
so when the circle game came out in that
episode of malcolm the middle if you
didn't watch that episode you got your
ass you got [__] beat to death the
next day you got your ass you got killed
bro and the circle game came out it was
a free for all of my school and we were
in the ghetto school at tanaya oh man
they made up so many references off of
it like double this triple that oh you
looked again off a mirror like shut the
[__] up just punch me in the arm
it just stop
um
but yeah
so
in conclusion for the first episode i
just want to say for everyone even if
you're brand new and this is the first
time you've ever heard us do anything
thank you for being here thank you for
supporting thank you for supporting um
just something that i've really really
wanted to do
and i'm super glad that me and marty
connected because he i feel like this is
it this is
this is what i really really want to do
i want to i just
i just want to talk to people man i just
want to talk to people get these
conversations i'm not i don't want to do
the regular
so what's your favorite [__] weed
strain
that's not what i want to do i want to
get conversations out of people that you
wouldn't expect i want to get the good
[__] i want to get stuff i want
something [__] to cry and i
want somebody focused to die laughing
you see what i'm saying i want some good
[__] like i said you're about to just go
for it i want some of you [__]
to die no dude
cry and die no hey man what the [__]
wrong with you that's not
i'm the same guy as early here god huh
we got waivers we got waivers yeah when
you sign it it's like a japanese game
show like you might get snakes thrown on
you when you're sitting in here
i might brand my logo on your leg
oh [__] yo i gotta stop let me keep
talking here we go guys thank you so
much for watching thank you for
supporting thank you for supporting push
trees the dopesyola everything
it's almost been nine years so for the
past my adult life
since i can remember i've just been
growing up on camera it's really odd to
see
the start just like the little funny
shitty pictures from my iphone 3
and now we're doing
[__] podcasts and
we had a million on [__] youtube
excuse me
on youtube and
everything's just going great
everything's going so well thank you
guys so much for supporting that's what
i really want to say thank you for
supporting and letting me have the
coolest job on the [__] planet
something that i've been saying since me
and my uncle john were smoking weed in
the backyard one day i just want to
smoke weed for a living
and it happened man well not fully just
smoke we we do a lot more [__] but you
guys get the base of it that's it's
the best job on the [__] planet i
couldn't
be more happy to know that i get to do
this [__] tomorrow
i get to do another episode of this we
get to do more stuff more [__]
adventures 2021 we have some stuff lined
up that's not just
oh you're you're a [__] uh uh
instagram kid that's why oh you do
instagram it's not a job
oh trust me it is
16 hours a day
it's you know
but now we're on youtube like i said
we're doing different platforms we've
got the website dopesyo.com
uh check out drastic graphics on
instagram
uh twitter too marty no not really no
yeah twitter's hard torches uh
where's the pictures unsplashed though
we just hit that half a mil on our first
like oh [__] nice splash is like a
photographer app or website and marty
shit's killing it on there marty just
filmed [__] super bowl commercials
guys this is a big year for marty also
man this is uh
he's been doing so much work in all
these other podcasts
but
not being
he's been doing the like i i i'm gonna
speak for you a little bit just from
what i've seen you put in a lot of
footwork without having a foot in the
company yeah you know what i'm saying
which is not a bad thing that's your
work that's what you do
but it's it's cool
because my own company yes you built
your own company to help those companies
but in the end it's like yo
i really wish i could get on the ground
floor of this and had a part of these
podcasts
but it's nothing it's your job that's
what you do that's awesome it's
different chapters now this is part this
is us this is not just my [__] this is
us so
everything's just gonna
everything's just gonna work man
everything's gonna work i i [__]
appreciate all you guys
marty's
like i said like 15 times well if i you
film super bowl commercials this year it
is so crazy you have super bowl
commercials and when we're watching the
super bowl party it's gonna pop up and
some of that footage is yours man i'm
not right so that was just yours
it's the coolest thing it's the coolest
[__] thing ever man i just i love it
so much that's that that's bad ass and
uh
now we got this going we got so much
[__] going dope as usual
it's just fun i'm happy to be here i'm
happy to honestly i'm just happy to have
another outlet to talk to you guys
you know because we do story time we do
uh lives it's not the same this is
i don't know this is uh
something more i feel this is more
important to me than just doing lives
this is
one place for all the fans to chill yeah
man i want to smoke throw it on let's
hang out let's smoke
this is what i mean like there's another
chance to talk to you guys more unedited
completely raw this is unedited
it's just
i don't know here's my fuck-ups here's
me [__] up here's me stumbling over
my word just make call like it's it's
it's more i feel like it's more real
it's more authentic and when we have
guests on here
i'm really excited to have conversations
with these people
that's my main thing i love having
conversations and now that i can have a
conversation maybe it's
your favorite skater your favorite
rapper or up and coming this or a
financial advisor of that and you know
these people you're like wow oh you got
them on your show i really want to hear
what they got to say
that's what i want you guys to see like
oh wow you have this person on this
could be interesting i want you guys to
learn some [__] i guess i told marty i
want you guys to
come away with something these solo
episodes yeah i'm sure you're not going
to learn like what merced has meth like
that's not what you're going to come
away with but i'm saying i want you guys
to come in with these interviews more of
insight insightful you know what i mean
it's not just
the run-of-the-mill same questions that
you've always heard on interviews i want
i want people to talk about stuff you
never would expect i want your favorite
artist to talk about
their sister trying to [__] stab them
or some crazy [__] that they don't put
in their songs or in their books i just
want that raw real [__] like i said life
accomplishments [__] ups everything in
between that's the whole point of this
is to talk about everything uh we're not
perfect we [__] up i [__] up many
times and i've been i've
i've got my ass whooped i've gotten shot
at i've gotten a bunch of [__] just like
you i know you're at home like me too
for i just got shot at right now oh bro
there's crazy [__] we've all grown up in
wild places and if you haven't
the shit's real
[__] do the [__] so don't judge
a book by its cover you know what i'm
saying the nicest looking guy might be
the hardest [__] street person you
know to do with tattoos on his face
might be a really nice person you can't
just judge people
i look super nice and all that [__] you
would never guess i had [__] 30
pounds in the trunk officer
you would never guess that because i had
my customer service voice how are you
doing today oh nice uh what can i get
you that's me from working in all these
places
that was my cover i had a job only to
cash check so i didn't get [__] my
door kicked in but you would never guess
it because i'm so [__] nice looking
and i look so oh you look like a college
student yeah yeah i kind of do so
and if you see marty like you carried a
screw in your pocket
marty can you look at the camera real
quick so have they seen your face yet
yeah you're like the nicest guy ever
like
yo i don't want to [__] across marty
it's at a liquor store
get a tall t-bump and twister oh
no man you might [__] me up yeah
it's awfully specific i don't know i was
just trying to think of something from
[__] 2009
i don't know or maybe you're above the
ti
all that yeah
so guys to in conclusion to wrap this up
we're almost at two and a half hours
thank you first if you sat here through
the whole thing you're a [__]
champion thank you so much um if you're
listening while driving please be safe
thank you for making us a part of your
day if it's the morning on the way to
work i appreciate you and if you're
finishing this episode on the way back
from work you're [__] awesome thank
you so much i hope we can make your day
a little better oh
i hope you laughed
i hope it was fun for you and when we
have other guests and if it was sad i'm
sorry but sometimes [__] got
sad [__] to say i'm excited for the
guests to come guys first guess is next
week really excited episode two is going
to be uh
first guest spot this is the
what do you call it wolverine origins
episode one just gotta let you know
where we're from there we go we're hugh
not hugh jackman we're wolverine origin
story okay this is episode one this is
where we're coming from
thank you guys so much for watching this
is the dope as usual podcast the dopest
podcast in the world and we're gonna say
that right now we're only saying that
because we have confidence in this thing
and it sounds cool the dopest podcast in
the world sounds pretty [__] epic if
you guys have something better leave it
in the [__] comments that will help
us out thank you guys so much for
watching episode one dope as usual
podcast i'm dope aziola from me for
marty drastic graphics thank you so much
for watching have a dope ass day
nice
[Music]
perfect